e
e e
it doesn't matter where you're sitting
you can move the name
tag they're
portable okay good morning everybody uh
we're ready to go ahead with a
subcommittee for the four bills which we
discussed yesterday all Finance Orient
our policy bills with a fiscal note that
has to we have to get these things out
by February the 15th
uh the bills which we're going to be
discussing today are 1583
1686 and
1656 it's very confusing there's a lot
of sixes in there and and a lot of five
so um and they're all dealing primarily
with the topic of how we fund
education and there's some commonality
between all these bills maybe not in in
the concept but there is there there
there's a commonality is they're dealing
with you know how do we support special
education how do we deal with this and
that and so there in our discussion here
um you're you can't talk one bill in
isolation because you're also going to
be impacting another bill so my intent
is that we we we your bill is a little
bit different represent luno than some
of the others which are dealing with
specific elements within a current
Formula yours is also dealing with you
know that but it goes
beyond so so I'm I'm not going to be
discussing like opening up now we're
going to discuss
1583 we're going to start opening that
we're going to open up and start working
on uh some of the matters which are
contributing to this and then narrowing
it down to specific bills so what I'd
also like to say right now is this is
not where we're going to be meeting on
the
19th um uh this room is really not
conducive for a a committee like this to
work closely together so we're represent
Emer sitting beside me from Finance has
kindly offered his room downstairs on
the first floor which is really
conducive to on on yeah on on the First
on second floor 209 yeah excuse me yeah
it's above where I was thinking I I was
thinking the Senate Finance room
upstairs right above it and so on the
second floor down on the left hand side
is where we will be meeting and that
room is really brings us closer together
and work as a real working committee
rather than having to look down and see
what represent Luna's doing down there
Beyond represent mile which is often
times hard to see and and the same thing
with with uh looking down this end too
here to represent spillsbury
so 209 yeah
209 so what I'm going to do initially
here is pass out information that
everybody we we're going to be talking
about and you may not have some of that
in front of you right now for example
represent cascaden do you have a copy of
the Blue
Book you you brought yours okay so every
does everybody have a copy of that
because we do have other copies in the
office
here okay so I'm going to hand out some
materials right now and they're not for
discussion this moment but there's
things we may be looking at as we go
through so you can put it in your in
your binders or wherever you want to put
it okay why don't we go that way with
these and that way with
those and there's no order in which I'm
passing these things out it's just
information that's going to be maybe
perhaps valuable to some of the
discussion which we may
have that one goes this way
you get three minutes to read all this
well I'm
gonna I'm not going to give you the
cliff notes but
uh we need anybody from
here well we can discuss that for for
what we plan on doing this morning we're
going to be looking at these some of
these past reports which have come out
on funding education we'll see look at
the original 20 uh it came out in 2008
that was the report which Senator
esbrook was chair of for how we allocate
base costs differentiated dat Etc and
then we'll flip to the 2018 report uh
just uh just briefly make sure everybody
has it and and knows that we may be
referencing part of that or looking at
the recent report that came out from the
commission study which is in the blue
binder um there will be other
information we may want to talk so
that's what we're going to basically be
doing this morning in the afternoon
we're going to have reporting coming in
regarding these bills from Department of
Education and from Department Revenue
Administration and then following that
we'll make a you know have a
brainstorming session right here as to
okay how we can attack and and move
forward um in regard to the four bills
okay
um the next is coming around there's
multiple copies within this see we how
many do we have to write here that's
five here
three
four five they're already in bundles I
need one of those too
trra okay so we might as well get it all
out
um I'm not going there will be a reports
no I'm not going to make copies of
everything no I I I'll talk to you later
about
that got to remember this is a committee
that's been put together by the speaker
and the minority leader of the the house
so with that um we're going to be
functioning a little bit differently
than some of the regular subcommittees
where's this one coming
from did are there enough copies for
everybody here
represent did you oh you already got it
down that then oh okay I I was think we
had to go both ways
okay let's see what we have next
here that was just handed me by Maguire
okay that goes that way okay
okay see what we got
here okay let's just make sure when you
got them all that everybody has a copy
of everything here does everybody have a
copy of the 2008
report okay there's also some backup
material for that which shows how the
inputs were for that backup report and
how they were developed
okay okay good got
that there is also uh a sheet that was
handed to me this morning by represent
McGuire I have not had a chance to look
at this it's a possible Amendment uh
dealing with
swep
okay there's a New Hampshire
foundational opportunity program program
information sheet here which was
provided by represent luno and passed
around it's
blue this also was just recently uh put
together and passed around by represent
luno so we got
that there's
a
report see I I don't know if these are
stapled together or not uh subcommittee
work session uh for
2022 um see what a establishing a
foundation opportunity budget program
for
funding
um I don't know it's just it's just a
report from 2022 of sub activity there's
also the report from represent umberger
which is the report of the 2018
and there's also a bill as was
introduced back in
2011 and there's within that 2011 on one
of the back pages there's how at one
point in time there was a suggestion how
to deal with swep which we might want to
look at
and lastly I have a report here provided
by the Department of Education which was
provided us back in November 15 20 23 uh
deals with uh current law adequacy Aid
per pupil
fy2 and the conel adequacy aid per pupil
and does not consider the ran case and
only Chang is making base adequacy Aid $
7,356
And1 that's so sort of like a small
spreadsheet
okay yes represent Casen thank you Mr
chair just wanted to point out that I
believe um if not all the documents you
passed out this morning might be still
uh uploaded on the car SE Institute
website because a lot of these we used
in our commission work but it would be
available at the car SE UNH Cary
Institute website for those who want to
know the and this is that's a good point
and this is why I've asked Jen to sit at
the table with us Jenifer four who is
our
research uh what's your official title
assistant
director director assistant director so
you got and and then yourself so she's
here to work with us
and it was mentioned to me this morning
earlier that that is also available
where would they find this information
like these reports on the department
site or on on this this s
lb
y okay
okay and if we need to you know um have
reference to some of the Constitutional
aspects we will be discussing you can go
to the Cary or or Jen could even put a
link out for that that those links were
there I saw that last night that she
sent out an email with all those links I
think was to you represent spillsbury
so
yep so with that I'd like to um just for
our quick discussion so everybody
everybody here was not here back in 2011
or or 2008 and there's background
information there which leads to where
we are today with the formulas and and
it even goes back further than that but
I don't think were you here with augen B
I was not yeah you were a Deputy
Commissioner back then yes you were
working thank you so I'd like to start
out with that 2008 and just do h a look
at that report quickly uh then and
because this all background information
which will relate to what we're doing uh
today this is the one that looks with
that big red Capital dome in the center
of it and there was a sheet which I
passed out which it might be easier to
look at appendix
a that comes right out of that
report this deals with the inputs as
they were established back then and we
I'm sure we'll be talking about inputs
versus performance at on the other side
of the point um so the inputs are there
and appendix
a shows you those elements or components
Within the base
cost the base cost of course is the cost
that on the leftand side of our present
current formula is what we uh in terms
of adequacy uh allocate per pupil along
with the differentiated but we're
looking right now only at the base cost
so you see that there was an amount put
in for teachers and teacher salary you
back then was $3 33,8
and they added in a 5% salary increase
and the benefits of 33% and they came
out with the total cost of a teacher at
$ 47,2
67 then they also looked at and this is
another area we may want to look at and
we will be looking at I'm sure somewhere
along the way if we're talking about um
uh this in terms of either ways we're
going to fund education the pupil
teacher ratio in the classroom how we
base that on
and for K through two you can see on the
next line down it was one teacher per 25
students that's what that
basic cost is built upon and stud and
20% for specialty teachers added on and
then there was for grades 3 through 12 a
ratio of 1 to 30 students with a 20% for
specialy teachers added
on there is also in this as a component
a principle of a
building and the principal was salary of
$5,151
5% salary increase and you can see the
benefit package of 28% and the total
cost was
$11,000 $111
14,014 and for they have that ratio one
principal per 500
students so going on down uh principal
administr strative assistant you can see
the same thing there and that cost is
you know was uh $42,715
that's that's it right well if there's
instructional materials
[Applause]
uh there was technology professional
development facility operation there's
Transportation there all these items
would come into this
formula so this is something we might
want to look at in terms of if if we are
still operating upon the obviously the
one of those cases is said the average
cost of a teacher might be
$57,000 is that the average of all is or
is are we taking the first year teacher
the third year teacher when the that was
all discussed within the 2008
study um going away from that right now
because I don't want to put our time on
the past but there's been some
discussion even
yesterday uh is there a relationship
between student achievement and chent
student growth and property valuation
and
poverty and in the 2018 report I'm still
looking at that same bundle of materials
but there's this sheet right here which
shows achievement we went looked at the
Statewide uh assessment which is
given and we found that in group one
which was comprised of all those
communities with a property valuation of
$660,000 or less there were 26 districts
that that fit into that column right
there into that
category in quartile one there's four
quartiles on our testing uh quartile one
is at the bottom you're moving up to
where their uh students are really
achieving well at to a quartile of four
uh a result of four you can see in that
first category of those 26 19
districts 73% of those districts were in
cortile
one and and
yes um this this sheet right here if you
keep on marching through after you get
through what was in the packet dealing
with the 2008 you'll find it like the
fifth page yeah I I didn't have time to
number them yeah um you can go through
and see how that works because in
quartile four in those districts only
7.5% of the students fit in that
quartile of four as achievement test you
go to the other side to the Other
Extreme and you go to group four which
they had a property valuation of $1
million or more per
pupil and it's the flip it's a reverse
how many students were in the low
achieving quartile 19% there were 122
districts in this
category of those which were fitting
into cortile 4 41 districts or 34% were
in that top you know fourth quartile in
Statewide assessment so there is a
relationship further if you go to the
next
sheet this is a sheet where we took the
and worked with the Department of
Education and this is data that's older
but I'm sure it's still very reflective
of what we're I'm trying to communicate
the next sheet has Berlin at the top
North umberland Claremont so is
everybody on that page looking through
it this one right
here this is a sheet where we took the
average Proficiency in math and reading
and the cortile if they have a one they
were in that lower cortile on the
Statewide assessment the next one over
is the equiz valuation uh cortile and
you notice the school districts that
have a one and a
one how it works out represent cascaden
that town you live in was right there on
top of the
list you can also go over to the extreme
right side of that uh sheet that was
done and we were looking at what is the
the pupil teacher ratio in those
particular
communities at that time I not know if
that's the case today but in grades 1
and two in your District represent uh
cascaden it was 23
to1 in grades three four it was 19 to1
I'm trying to read my you know printing
there and grade 5 through wait it was 20
to1 you can go down the list and see how
those all All Shook out but there's a
definite relationship if you're in that
lower cortile for uh equalized property
valuation chances are your District's
going to be either in a one or a
two so going on to the next sheet just
this is information which we've had the
next sheet is also explanation of that
one right
there the next sheet is uh dealing with
special education
you go down one
more and as you recall last year there
was a bill which we we uh in from the
policy perspective when we came to the
area of differentiated aid for special
education we were looking at is it
appropriate or proper that we allocate
one value one costing value for all
special educ ucation kids we have over
30,000 kids in special education in the
state to have an
IEP and there was an attempt to do it by
a weighted value and the weighted value
concept is done in numerous States
throughout the United States and it's
also reflective in some of the reports
which we will be talking about but this
is an attempt that we have done and when
we talking about IEPs and special
education those 13 IEP categories down
below so you can Rel you can look at
that and say well there's some kids that
maybe have speech once or twice a week
for a half hour from a speech
pathologist but there's other students
that may be orthopedically handicapped
or have a traumatic brain injury or one
of those other categories which requires
much much more time and attention to
that youngster in school or student and
so um how would we get that information
you go to the next sheet
and there is a reporting process that uh
I can get to that sheet here that the
Department of Education has for the
federal government yes that's the the
this one right
here this information is available it
just has to be put into some format of a
spreadsheet and and gotten for us so
this is a topic that if you care to go
that way in our discussions um we can go
in that direction but it it is available
uh individuals with Disabilities Act
idea Part B an indicator 5 requires this
information um going
further I think that's all that's in
that packet right there that we need to
talk at this point in
time other information what you do have
is the the umberger report I don't think
there's a great need to get get into a
lot of discussion on that there's a a
majority report and there's a minority
report attached to that uh document
um uh chair lad yes yeah before we get
too far away from what we were just
reviewing yes um the last part of your
discussion I mean all all the all of the
presentation is very interesting the uh
particularly with the um the part uh
surrounding the three categories a b and
c
of special education Aid how were the um
how were the
weights um determined I guess oh based
on like the
existing what what what that was yes we
took the existing what we have and that
would be the category a you know the the
student getting Speech Pathology twice a
week or something they would get that
IEP costing value but the going down to
the next one we're starting to talk
about students which
are needing much more service and so you
can see that there's kind of a ratio
between going from one to the other
whereas you get to category three which
is the residentially placed youngster
which is
double and that that whole scheme is the
dollars were trying to be built around
uh it wasn't
really a program based upon it was part
partially built on program where we're
recognizing this is a concept that
probably should be in the costing amount
needs work and and and there wasn't time
to do that okay yes representative he
just a question with regard to that what
is the source of the information in
terms of cost by the categories that
you're discussing is that available is
it on the
doe2 I I don't believe it
is so that see now we do have we do have
uh Mark coming in this afternoon I when
when I initially went after this
information I was able to get it from uh
Caitlyn Davis also at doe she was able
to tell me you have this many students
which are ABS actually residentially
placed maybe in Tennessee or maybe in
some school which houses them with
tuition and board and all that uh here
in our own state that information we
have we know that's roughly around
somewhere around 600 to 700 students and
that I'm using rough figures because I
don't have the accurate figure for this
year and then we were able to break it
down with the other students which we're
talking about by category and there was
some discussion with Rebecca fet on that
but most of that was basically coming
from discussing with some of the special
ed directors throughout the state not
many done so so Rick Rick what I was
really trying to get I think Mary's
trying to get at it too is th these
numbers are formula cost so basically
the differentiated Aid factors they're
not cost for providing special education
services for those for those are you to
the dollar amount for category a yeah
yeah looking looking at the 37 million
for a and the 38 million for B and the
where's the
C where was
see um
well
it yeah the what what you're talking
about are the the the what's in our
formula now for differentiated
Aid I
I the weighted the weighted formula if
you're looking in the materials came out
of the 2020 is like it's a weighted
value of 4.2 t 29 times that base amount
which you juggled I think it was around
$6,500 or so or somewhere around that
neighborhood you to multiply that to get
the amount which comes up to
that uh $27 million
figure what we had done is that in
looking at this uh we had taken and
built a it's
not directly related to how much time
and what the actual cost is for
delivering the services for a student
that has a uh uh multiple handicaps or
we didn't do that we didn't have that
source of information available to
us represent kiss can I I think to
answer um representative lud's question
is that when the schools fill out the
idea Part B Grant they they classify it
three categories so like category a do
they spend more than 80% of a day in a
classroom and then do they spend less
than 40% or are they in residential
I'm thinking that's where it came from
because you got a fact sheet yes is
exactly what we use indicators y we use
that information that's on that data
fact sheet that comes from the federal
government yeah right partant but but
that's not getting to my question Oh My
My My question is about what are the
what are the actual District costs for
these students not what is in our
current funding
formula no would be on the this isn't
about District cost this about funding
for this is an issue which we want to
get in here on the doe 25 form we have
to break down those expenses in terms of
specifically what we're talking about
rather than using that generality here's
what we have as an expense and dividing
by the number of students here's what
the cost is for that District we need to
be looking at program as well AB
absolutely but and for each of these
categories is that that's why it's going
to take some work yeah yeah and and how
those categories are matched up there
right now is based on an experiential uh
perspective from myself when I did it
and working with directors out in the
field and trying to get an es is this
one that belongs in that 80% or
requiring that much more than that time
less about that or
40% that's in in the federal guideline
gives us some perspective of how to do
this and I and I think that's about what
we're going to get right now with the
time we
have so yeah Mary might have some I I
just wanted to mention I do have a bill
in this year oh yes I realize that I do
have a bill in this year just to do this
um but in my research for my bill Most
states do contribute at different levels
um I think if you look at the education
Commission of the states they have some
excellent information that provides a
lot for that but it concerns me um I
think um representative cascaden is
referring to a form that the is required
for special education folks to fill in
so I think if we really dig deep we
might be able to come up with better
costs for those children so that we have
guidance better guidance than what we
have here yes and that's what we tried
to do and we didn't get that information
back from doe I do have the education
committee uh commission the state's
report uh that representative Heath is
alluding to out on the desk out there
it's just amazing looking at the weight
of values and some of the states which
are doing this now like a Florida Texas
uh you know New Jersey there most of
them have a weighted value rather than
one taking all these and then taking the
average uh because it's not the same in
every district oh it's so differentiated
it it's so different and so that's we
need to be cognizant of this aspect in
anything we
do okay yes yes yeah it's a good
discussion one of the things that um I
think we really need to be sensitive
about in small rural districts um if in
fact a a severely
disabled CH a child enters a a school
district um there are a lot of factors
that get thrown in at Town meetings and
and it throws the entire budget off so I
think we've got to think about that as
we think about what we're going to do
with special ed in terms of those kinds
of costs because one child can just
throw an entire budget off um for a
local school district a small one yeah
that that's the catastrophic aid but
it's also more than catastrophic Aid I
can tell you a specific case occurred in
sau23 we had students the needed Speech
Pathology this is back a few years back
when Mark Joyce Dr Joyce was uh working
with the school administrator
Association the only way that Hil could
get a speech pathologist is through a
contracted service from conquer yeah and
at that time there was money
available for transportation of this
it's gone it's gone
now that's another burden that's on
these districts in the teacher shortage
committee which we had we found that
this is one of the categories which is
very very short in term you know
difficult to find some of these trained
people that we need to have in our
schools and so some much of it's done in
the state now through contracted service
that is expensive and so you're correct
and unfortunately your commission
studies is not going to be done prior to
the our responsibility
here sure yes yesterday you commented on
the catastrophic need we're not
considering
that as part of this committee is that
well I understand correctly
well currently currently catastrophic
Aid is not part of the adequacy formula
it's a separate formula as you you you
do in division two and and if our task
is if we're looking at you know adequacy
as is in front of us differentiated Aid
you know um extraordinary needs Grant
which is not part of that's a grant
program but it's not there and and I
think that the commission that represent
Heath's going after is that's a broken
broken formula too seeing that you you
know you the first well we'll use the
figure of of $20,000 a kid the first
three and a half times that would be
you'd have to spend $70,000 first as a
community before you're going to get any
state aid that's 70 grand year and
that's yeah in your budget's based on
the previous year and then from three
and a half times to 10 times the cost
per pup the state kicks in 80% you still
have that 20% differential you're going
to have to pay for once it gets over the
10 times the state kicks it in but by
that time a small District that only has
maybe 70 to 100 students they're having
to look elsewhere for the dollar to do
this Unfortunately they have to go
borrow the money they have to take it
from some other aspect of their
operating budget so you're borrowing
from Paul to pay Susan over here um it
doesn't
work and we we've tried to address
pooling and all that that's not working
hasn't started um that was a bill I
think representative Hill passed or got
through it several years back there was
uh some support from other organizations
trying to get that going where districts
could pull and put money in and know how
to budget for catastrophic Aid um that
has not occurred
so I'm not saying it it can't be
discussed if we want if you want if we
think oh that belongs in in
adequacy that was a comma yeah I got a
the other part of the question is
category C the 600 students that are
residential that seems to be
catastrophic to me so are is there
something is category is there something
more than category C I mean somebody
away
residentially it doesn't get much more
catastrophic right I I understand that
what we're trying to do is slip and
that's a category which that student is
a resident in your district and comes
down on your student membership correct
yeah so so are do they what are they
going to get for you know differentiate
Aid that $2,300 or are they going to
recognize that that student is going to
there's going to be more cost to that
student there is to a category B student
that so that's why we put it in my
question is is category C in and of
itself catastrophic
Aid as it was proposed there as part of
differentiated Aid and then catastrophic
Aid would kick in um also but you get a
little bit more support from the state
okay got it yeah got it all right there
another way of trying to address this we
knew we couldn't change cat a so this we
were're going to do it here okay so Mr
chair yeah just just wondering um uh we
obviously have limited time because
February 15th these bills have to be out
but um but what what are we thinking as
far as work process going work path
going forward with the four bills and I
mean this is great discussion here and I
think it will come up with with with
these bills particularly as we you know
like one of the bills is just about
special education funding yeah and uh
and so this is going to be great
background discussion for that but um
what what's your thought about work path
um okay so that's what I was planning on
doing after we had the you know
discussion this afternoon with uh doe
and with Dr then to say okay where what
is the work path what are we going to
ask for more information we know we're
going to need this for discussing your
bill we're going to have to for
discussing the bill which dealt with the
differentiate for special
education and uh so guess my question
inform did we want to talk about the
bills this morning well we will as once
we get through these reports and then we
will in a few seconds here because we've
gone through basically you know one of
and the umberger report is came out with
certain recommendations which got there
but we never talked about any of the
specific inputs okay thank you and and
so that I think does take us through
these
reports um the only other one that I a
sheet that you have there was because we
have a bill on swep and that's a part of
two of the
bills uh there was a on the back part
this was just another wait we saw the
amendment that was proposed by uh
represent Maguire and what he's doing is
just lowering that 363 million
downwards and I don't want to discuss it
right now represent we will and and what
this one does uh if you looked on page
six of that HB
337 um it says a municipality May remit
the balance of such exes or any portion
thereof to the Department of Revenue
Administration as provided paragraph in
this paragraph or retain the balance of
such excess to be used in the current
fiscal year year or a future fiscal year
to offset the cost of school building
construction or renovation project to
offset catastrophic special education uh
in costs incurred provided that
notwithstanding the eligibility
Provisions set forth in RSA
19815 through 19815 AG you
and W in uh 186c the municipality shall
exhaust such excess as condition of
eligible so what it's basically trying
to say is that you can keep it but
you're going to have to use it for these
purposes that was a concept rather than
having to return it did this become law
no it wasn't it wasn't appreciated by
the house and but this is another
concept of how to deal with swep if you
if you're
right there was a session in fact on
that particular
bill um it was put forth by representa
hes Flanigan lad Kirk Benton court and
Jasper and when it came out that stuff
was stripped and a number of those
people didn't vote for the bill that was
the same bill that we we took the money
out of the left side of the column
through it in the other side in $150
million in stabilization Etc
and and and here we are
today
so I guess I've gone through all that we
can at this point in time uh open up
this discussion to those four bills and
strategies how we want to address 1583
86 1686 and
56 so it's open any ideas here how you
like to go at
it Mr chair yes yeah I so I would
suggest given the the um looking at the
U uh the four bills three of them are
clearly related to uh to funding
formula and uh and the the fourth bill
um is related to uh specifically to um
swept reform and um and I I would offer
i' I'd love to you know sort of quickly
walk people through the technical
details behind 157
1586 um and it's 26 pages long and I
don't think we need to belabor every
every line of it but uh go through the
section review and um and a lot of that
area is going to touch on obviously
areas in the first two bills that talk
about base and the special education
differentiated weight
Factor everybody agree with that
sure the the last bill
1656 um or not 1656 the the bill doing
the the swep that involves every Bill
too doesn't it and and it does in a way
so that that's in 1586 as well yesly um
so you know I think 1586 serves as a as
a good uh place for a robust discussion
that talks about things that the other
ones relate to as well now the the the
ones that deal with base cost and
special those are really components
within the input system we press
presently had corre that's right so
it's well let's just go on let's take up
yours first and and and talk about that
you have a sheet what you handed out
walk us through it and I'd like to do
that could um and and one more thing as
we go through all this if anybody has a
question don't wait till the end ask it
immediately so we don't forget
it he thank so I'd like to go up there
and can um
Mr than
welcome
put chair members of the special
committee thank you for uh
inviting us here to um uh to discuss the
uh technical aspects behind House Bill
1586 I feel like we've been up here
before
yes um there's a couple of um couple of
handouts that passed around earlier one
of them is uh this right here and it's a
a slide deck that really introduces the
foundation opportunity program and what
what the uh what the intent of uh of 50
1986 is all about the other one is a is
a um an overview or a summary of the uh
of the bill in terms of section by
section and uh and I think if it um if
it makes sense for for uh Mr ardinger
here that we'd sort of quickly go
through the slide deck and then spend a
little more time going through the
sections and uh certainly appreciate I
think as chair lad has uh has offered
interactive um discussion if if um CHL
add does that that's that's what we want
okay fantastic so Bill do you want to
lead us through you well you you you put
a lot of these slides together so again
for the members of the committee who
were here yesterday and before my name
is Bill ardinger uh I am um an attorney
in Conquer New Hampshire at wrath young
Pignatelli um I served as a member of
the commission with other folks here
including uh representative luno who
served as chair representative kiscaden
representative Ames and I'm gonna and
representative Heath I I'll make
mistakes in the room lad and Miler and
lad sorry it's everybody um and and and
so I am a strong supporter I appear here
as a strong supporter of the commission
report and uh of and house bill right
here which you have 1586 is an out uh
come of that commission report and its
conclusions it's an effort to implement
the conclusions and findings of the
commission it was one of the best
experiences I've had uh in New Hampshire
working with colleagues on that
commission it was it was a very uh
engaging process that the just going
through quickly this um uh PowerPoint
presentation the the bill is even though
it's long because education funding is
hard and it has lots of details it's
pretty straightforward it does six
things one it defines constitutional
adequacy it defines it in terms of
opportunities for good student
outcomes two it establishes a foundation
opportunity budget for every District
this is the budget that is projected
based on the mechanisms in the bill to
allow every District to have the
resources they need to help their
children hit the defined constitutional
adequacy Target three it focuses state
budget Aid to districts based on their
unique circumstances and challenges if
uh a particular and that the details are
in the Bill and those will be subject
for your review but just in summary
based on the attributes and
characteristics that are in the
Bill the the the mechanism the formula
in
1586 takes the total resources of the
foundation opportunity budget and
allocates it to districts based on their
unique challenges in other words some of
you heard yesterday I was a graduate of
Stevens High School in Claremont
Claremont faces unique challenges today
Claremont would get a greater allocation
a larger Foundation opportunity budget
than other communities who don't face
such direct unique challenges four this
bill incorporates it in into it
something that's fundamentally related
to what the commissions task was it
incorporates a um uh a a property tax
relief component a
restructuring of the Statewide property
tax this commission has not entered into
what is a very good discussion I'm I'm
born and raised a tax lawyer and does
tax policy and had this all tax policy
discussions are very important they
should be had all the time they should
raise uh you know questions about the
pros and cons of various taxes this
particular proposal retains the
Statewide property tax but it suggests
important changes
that representative Ames actually
authored in uh his bill on this it
provides low
income uh property tax payers with
important and increased relief it also
provides uh an answer uh to the Rand
Court uh type of issue where it says
that the Statewide property tax which is
a state tax is going going to be
collected from all the taxpayers placed
into the education trust fund and then
used as one of the sources like the
business Enterprise tax which is paid
for by all the taxpayers and the
business profits tax component this pay
it goes in and then is used to satisfy
the obligations of the budget in here F
fifth it provides transition grants this
bill to
communities it is unbelievably important
I look at representative cascaden who
has experien with these districts like
and representative lad and my my wife um
uh the project the Enterprise of Public
School Systems is very Capital intensive
and has fixed costs like Collective
bargained agreements and commitments and
and building costs and capital costs it
is absolutely nonsensical to propose any
change to school funding with without
making sure that we aren't creating
shocks that harm any community in their
Endeavor to get to uh a better answer
for the whole state which I believe 1586
is and so it provides trans and funds
transition grants to communities to make
sure that the transition doesn't shock
them finally importantly required by the
Supreme Court in the clar line of cases
this bill provides a detailed account
accountability rules and it's integrated
with the definition of account of of of
adequacy a lot really in the current law
you don't have a good integration when
you do adequacy defined by input
costs you can't really say you can't
really determine in a clear way whether
the district is achieving the goals for
the program uh because all they have to
do is are they having a teacher with
Masters are they having computers
whatever your cost inputs are in this
case this bill defines constitutional
adequacy in terms of student outcomes
and then provides clear data and
enforceability requirements that make
sure that the state which has the duty
to make sure every child has has a uh
access to a a good education regardless
of where they live it makes sure that um
the state
government is watching to make sure that
uh there are no uh children falling
through the gaps and where there where
the data demonstrates that there may be
a problem it provides the mechanisms in
increasing stringency to address any
deficits and gaps it's that's the bill
it it's a it's comprehensive it has six
parts yes it's not just focused on one
teeny piece it like the commission which
had 12 months to study this it tries to
get a comprehensive answer that will
hopefully put to rest the kind of
continuing wrangling we've had over this
uh these issues for decades thank
you yes go ahead ref Ames thanks you
said to ask questions when and not
otherwise we'll forget them I would
forget um but uh I just want to note
that
the um the Statewide education property
tax component that's in this bill that
you mentioned um resolves the excess
swept issue in a different way
than HB
1686 the other bill
that's that directly addresses excess
swept 1686
says return the excess to the
state after you've
allocated that part which is not excess
without trying to Define that
um then you return the excess my bill
says collect the tax this is a state
tax and remit the entire proceeds to the
state and then then that money goes into
the pot and goes out according to the
formula uh it never it does not stay
local so they're very different
approaches to uh to this and we can talk
a lot more about the pros and cons but I
just wanted to get that
out right and and um and representative
Ames uh the bill you're talking about um
that was um voted interim study Ways and
Means and on the floor so it's an
interim study and I think in in in the
the back half of um of
1586 very very similar to what you what
you described here and the important
thing to realize where all of it's
collected locally 100% of remitted to
the uh to the Dr deposited into the
education trust fund as Mr aringer said
the the net out of of of uh of swept
from adequacy is take it's it's
currently it's netted out in the uh in
19842 some 41 42 I think it's 42 um that
part is taken out so that so that
districts will get their adequacy Grant
as in the current Formula back from the
directly from the state and the one
qualification in in representative Ames
Bill and that was incorporated into this
is that there are processing fees uh
that are are kept just like meals and
rooms their processing fees kept locally
to for the cost of the collection and
that's in this bill so I would I would
like to just if I could turn to just the
second page of this presentation we've
gone through the six comms on the bill
but this is the fundamental purpose for
this reform package in the commission
work there was a stud we had an expert
firm paid come to do a study of New
Hampshire's Current public education
then current a few years ago public
education system and its conclusions
that were most critical to me are
presented in this graph what it shows is
that compared to other New England
states New Hampshire's division of total
public education resources we spent
about 3.5 billion on public education
the distribution of those resources
among districts is regressive in other
words even though you may have poorer
families as represented by uh various
poverty measures a greater poverty you
end up not
receiving as much Aid compare on this
graph if you would look at it New
Hampshire
with its graph SL sloping down to
Massachusetts which has worked after the
McDuffy case that represent to correct
its state Aid distribution so that it's
directing Aid to the communities with
the greatest need what Massachusetts has
achieved since
1993 is a graph that is not regressive
it is Progressive it's delivering Aid to
make sure that no children fall through
the Gap other states in New England are
struggling with the same issue the
commission's work was focused on one
basic question if you think of it in
graphical terms see that New Hampshire
line do what we can do to turn it the
other way so it looks like Massachusetts
line now interestingly representative
Heath
Manchester is a uniquely potent
statistic iCal force in New Hampshire if
we solve our Manchester problem which
maybe it wasn't intended maybe it was
but last session's work I was talking
with Mr Sheen kind of
got more State dollars to Manchester you
can move that line just by that but you
can't do it on oneoff Lost in the trees
detail type of you got to have a
comprehensive approach that applies year
over-year and allows the state to make
sure it's fulfilling its duty to
guarantee that every child has an access
to a good education so chairman luno I
just wanted to to emphasize that pure
that's the policy behind this bill turn
that
line um page three uh is uh again
confirms that current law is in New
Hampshire unfair and regressive what it
what that graph shows is that it looks
like by population almost all of our
school districts are lining up around
$4,100 there's a little movement here
and there but it's pretty much dead on
4100 see that that way they're presented
vertically you know why we're
Distributing a gigantic chunk of state
aid base Aid on a uniform per pupil
basis which is not focused on trying to
get and make make sure that we're
guaranteeing that every child has access
to a good education regardless of where
they live live it is a goal of this bill
to
move that graph so that the the
communities that have the lowest
equalized valuation per pupil end up
receiving greater adequacy a this is one
of the key things when a dollar an extra
goes into
Clara it can result in extra extra
education spending actually Claremont
works really hard to spend money on
public education or it can result in
property tax relief based on the local
government decision and so this graph
would uh by by getting our Aid to the
communities with the greatest challenges
including property tax based challenges
we achieve not only student Equity we
achieve property taxpayer equity and
when you throw in the sugar and spice of
Representative Ames in enhanced
lowincome property taxpayer relief
you're starting to really move the ball
uh do you have a second for a question
yes please cell um just a a question um
based on what I think I heard you say um
every dollar that you add to um The
District in Claremont or something um
results in property tax relief or
education advancement let's say um but
there's no
requirement that that dollar be spent on
academic issues is there I think
representative cordelli it's a great
question and my answer is there is and
here's where the requirement is while
this bill and I believe the Supreme
Court has always said that local
governance and loal local control is
important and is not prohibited by any
of the Claremont cases if the local
government is making
decisions without a constraint right
like you say a direct legal constraint
that is directing those dollars all to
property tax relief perhaps and maybe
even reducing their spending even
further on public education and then all
of a sudden the data comes in that
they're failing
children because this bill has very uh
heightened accountability requirements
at that point the state's role Rises not
before because listen New Hampshire is
doing pretty good on average we're
ranked third in the country in quality
but there are places where it's not
doing well and so we would the state
watches it representative cordelli with
the accountability data and if there is
a community where you pick the failure
it could be anything but local
governance could be a failure in that
case under this bill the state is
responsible to step in and take action
to make sure they protect those children
and guarantee their access to a good
education sure but in the situation we
have
today um each district gets um adequacy
based on the current formula but if you
take a look at the proficiency scores
you know half the kids can't read 40%
are proficient in math so you know where
is the accountability for there you know
you would think that the local taxpayers
would have something to say about that
but uh too often they're not aware I
think of the proficiency scores um so
I'm not sure you know where the
accountability comes in I'm not sure if
the accountability provided for in here
is going to make um the difference
because in my way of thinking it's more
more uh than just the dollars is uh part
of uh providing um for greater
achievement in our schools I couldn't
and I believe the commission couldn't
agree more when representative lad is
talking about inputs this inputs that
this that the a big change as I said to
in this approach is to Define
constitutional adequacy in terms of
quality and achievement outcomes because
that allows this information that you
say sometimes might get lost in our
Democratic processes both at the state
level and perhaps at the local level not
to get lost we want to raise up that
information of achievement of
performance of gaps and we want the
communities to increase the priority of
addressing those problems whatever
system this state adopts for public
education it has to be one that
addresses ultimately the concern that
you're talking about but I would just
follow on to that saying uh addressing
those concerns I don't think means uh
just providing more money to that
District I agree with that except this
that to add this you are right
if you look across communities in New
Hampshire you will find some communities
which have educ uh uh very strong family
backgrounds they had I was talking with
uh Mr Hall who's so good on this stuff
uh very strong family backgrounds very
high median Family household incomes
very strong commitments to education
those communities naturally through
their local government system will tend
to create more uh build Public School
Systems and it's not necessarily dollars
if I could just say that unlike current
laws input
based calculation of
adequacy this bill's determination of
adequacy takes those types of Social and
demographic issues into account for the
first time quality matters not just
costs and I think representative
cordelli if I would say I I've heard the
concern that you've expressed expressed
many times over my decades working on
this issue it is a valid concern and I
believe this bill and the commission's
work is actually representative Miler
said it the entire commission it's time
to focus on outcomes and I thought that
was a courageous position and and so I
think there is a way to come together on
this bill um uh in a way that hasn't
been in the past
one
more um I'll never forget a um I think
it was a book I read and I can't
remember the name I wish I could I want
to get it out of the library again um
but the study indicated that um uh
students who grew up in a one parent
household had um
x% possibility of escaping poverty in
their lifetime but I think lived in a in
a one parent household in a
neighborhood of one parent households
their chance of escaping poverty was
something like in single digits so I'm
not
sure you know if this formula or any
formula is going to address that kind of
situation if we really you know want to
talk about uh you know what the problems
are we want I represent cordelli number
one I think this formula in the
statistical analysis that helps get to a
defined constitutional
adequacy uh standard in terms of
outcomes here does take those factors
into account maybe not as much as you
like but I would also as you know I've
been around a long time and and grew up
in Cornish I would I would push back a
little bit and say I don't think you are
saying that a fair Foundation budget to
pay for the costs of this of a decent
Public School System doesn't have some
correlation with student outcomes
because that data doesn't exist it's so
you got to do all of it I would contend
respectfully
sir it just let me cut in then represent
Myer
um you know I went through a lot of this
discussion we're talking how we measure
performance outcomes and basically your
report this report does it on three
factors State uh Statewide assessment
assessment graduation rates and
attendance those three factors are used
within our Ouray right now we have a
whole lot of other factors which are
indicators of of of doing the job
delivering that adequate education and
we know them you know going on the
pathway CTE attendance military asab all
that so there other other measures but
if we're looking for some that's very
objective these measures you have are
objective other words you know they they
they lock it in however you know
performance
outcomes are there performance is also
measured and the input
system um and and I I I don't think that
system should be totally denied uh that
we we're looking at technical support
and supportive support is given to those
schools granted there might be high
schools that don't receive title $1
dollar so they may not be eligible for
those dollars but we also have it within
State They will receive support so um
you know I I'm not trying to degreg the
report but I'm also saying that the
other side of the coin there is
accountability and and uh maybe
structured a little differently so so
you know and I'm glad you mentioned that
chair lad because um you know that's one
of the um I think in uh inconsistencies
in our current education funding uh
framework and educ uh public school
education learning uh instruction
delivery framework is that we have uh we
have a definition of adequacy in um um
193 e 198 193 e2a 193 193 e2a
defines the sub criteria the sub
criteria for for delivering inadequate
education we've got a costing of an
adequate education based on 1500th of a
principal 130th of a teacher all this
other stuff and then we've got an
accountability to an adequate education
that is based to a large degree on
outcomes so we have a definition based
on um program studies a costing based on
what's in the bag and an accountability
based on how our kids are doing
doing and 1586 tightens that up
significantly by defining it based on
outcomes by costing it based on outcomes
not based on I'm Sorry by um costing it
based on all the for every District
being able to educate all of its
students to a Statewide outcome sorry
it's not costed based on outcomes it's
costed based on getting getting all the
students in that District to a Statewide
outcome in Manchester those costs are
going to be higher highest percentage
students living in low-income
backgrounds highest number of kids
English language Learners um all these
things very different in Manchester than
in
Handover but then the
accountability section of it ties right
back into into um achieving that
Statewide outcome when that
accountability
when when when it's identified that a
school district is not meeting that that
objective the uh the the
1586 and the the the formula behind it
does not increase the foundation
opportunity budget for that District
doesn't change that as representative
cordelli was suggesting throw more money
at the problem it doesn't do that there
are some federal programs that I think
attorney valinsky talked about those
yesterday that do you know provide
additional funds but the state is not is
not doing that through the provisions in
in 1586 the state is then as as attorney
arer has has said then providing those
districts with some expert help from the
from the state those superintendents
those principles um here here's here's
what this District very similar is doing
in terms of programs in terms of uh
Extended Learning opportunities in terms
of outside of school enrichment
activities that are helping to get them
where they're going and the information
that's collected by the department um
through the accountability section 15 86
allows them to have that information and
be able to share that information with
uh with districts that are struggling so
it's not it's not pumping pumping more
cash into the foundation opportunity
budget repent I first thank you Mr chair
I just want to emphasize the fact that
what I I what I think people need to
realize is that this program really
emphasizes the issue of quality and
outcomes uh our current program doesn't
do that it just says well you know
here's a bunch of money we're going to
just send it here and I think for school
districts it's going to be a terrific
challenge for the first time to
basically come forward and say okay here
are here's our goals are we meeting them
or are we not meeting them the other
thing that I think I I want to emphasize
here that this program becomes student
centered student
centered because it's focused on how
kids are going to be performing in that
school district and that's something
that the current formula does not
address as it relates to how students
are in fact doing and so that's I think
those two issues for making sure that
they're meeting their objectives if
they're not then they get some
assistance and that it is focused on how
students are doing in the school
districts thank
you represent dry then represent
represent dry thank you Mr chairman
um if the answer
to a school that's not meeting the
accountability is to give them help
provide them help one that doesn't come
with no cost I'm assuming but also are
we doing that at all now
are we doing that at all right now
that's a great question because I don't
know to what extent the department is
collecting that information with which
to say all right and you know District a
um you're you're you're underperforming
but I know what district you know B is
doing and very similar District to you
here's what you can do to help um I
would I'm I'm sure that
um that you know if um if Nate green
were here he'd be able to talk about uh
you know what the what the department is
uh is doing right now but given the fact
given the fact that that we've got
districts such as Newcastle where the
average student in Newcastle is
performing at the 84th percentile of all
students
Statewide and we've got the average
student in Manchester and I hate picking
on manchest but it's our largest
District um with a lot of challenges
where the average student in Manchester
is per performing at the fifth
percentile of all students
Statewide that whatever the department
is doing to try to provide some student
equity and some some some commonality
with with student the average student
outcome in Manchester shouldn't be that
different than the average student
outcome in Hopkinson
I mean it shouldn't be all that
different um uh there's going to be
little differences but
but it shouldn't be so
so extreme right now than what that when
you look at where the average student is
Manchester against 165,000 or 160,000
kids K12 public schools and they're
performing 90 95% of those kids are
performing better than than student
number SE student number 650 I'm sorry
6,500 in the um in the Manchester
schools I think I think what we ought to
do is try to move on here
and I think we can argue this case you
know this particular situation yes we
know there's a lot of poverty
communities out there and we know
there's a direct relationship between
achievement and and that that that um
and we have some issues we have some
issues in the present formula uh with
the lack of fiscal capacity topar 8 uh
but um I think that to address this um
it's going to be quite a lengthy topic
here because this is probably Pro a
foundational uh uh element that has
brought all this about is that we have
property poor towns which aren't putting
the product out
that for example graduation rate in the
state is around 92% it's pretty good
it's up in the top but if you take the
district you've just been talking about
there's some high schools high school
that has a 58% graduation
rate and um that that is a concern and
an issue Mr Mr Cher let me follow and
take just one more slide and then let
the I will step aside and let the
commission just to follow what uh
representative luno asked me to do let's
move the ball I agree uh one last slide
page seven it's a picture picture's
worth a thousand
words this bill when we put together the
financial spreadsheets and if you
haven't done an Excel spreadsheet for
the
240 uh districts with all of these I
urge you to do it because I contend that
you can't really understand the impacts
of Ed funding reform until you've done a
spreadsheet like that um when we did the
spread sheet we knew that what the
current system does is in the top graph
it has everybody receiving about the
same amount of money per
pupil regardless of their equalized
valuation
differences but when this machine in
1586 was turned on in a
model the result would be a distribution
of Aid that's shown in Green in the
bottom graph that shows stretching the
communities so that those with the
greatest
challenges are getting the greatest
support uh represent of heat it is not
picking on Manchester the state's Duty
under Claremont
one is to take a very cleare eyed look
where are our problems and means looking
hard and frankly every family in
Manchester should not View and teacher
an administrator should not view this as
critical should view it as the state
finally stepping up to its duty to help
the districts with greatest need that I
don't think we need to go as chairman L
and and it should be obvious from these
graphs the biggest bubble on here is
Manchester the second bubble is nashille
and so you can see you can see what what
1586 does for
moving these Bubbles and and and
aligning them where um where where uh
based on based on their challenges and
needs and as attorney AR said their
capacity to to meet their own needs so
so um so and that's that's very much
tied in with the uh with the with the
funding so what what what attorney
ardinger is talking this is the costing
part of it this has nothing to do with
funny this is costing what a foundation
opportunity budget would look like for
these different districts um when we get
to the funding uh side of it and um and
I think we could probably even shift
into doing um
u a quick summary of the funding so
we've got the foundation opportunity
budgets if you look on page 10 uh they
are set by the formula in the to achieve
the equity results by the way just to
let you know the five plaintiff towns in
the original claron action which
includes uh uh all do significantly
better under this approach than they do
under current
law um the the funding for these budgets
the foundation opportunity budget comes
from two
sources a minimum local
contribution that is
mandated and a state Foundation
Opportunity Grant those two integrated
sources hit the foundation budget
established for every Community as as he
said the foundation budget is is greater
in the communities with the greatest
challenges so those two sources now this
is a
controversial piece as as we talked
about yesterday at the hearing the
question has been raised whether this
integrated
mandated funding system mandated by
state law whether it is consistent with
with language in court cases in the
Claremont line and I think that's a fair
question but I also contend that the
courts decisions have never said that
there can't be a substantial role for
local governments and local
contribution and therefore the test as I
think I don't believe the court has ever
been presented with a fully completed
integrated quality-based
answer to defining constitutional
adequacy and guaranteeing funding for it
like this bill and because this bill
achieves in its
intent very good policy goals that I
believe were consistent with the
original intent of the five poor school
districts that challenge the state's
lack of Duty in 19 in in that resulted
in the Claremont one decision I think
the court uh it it's difficult to say
how the court would come out on this um
there's it is a fair question I don't
want anyone to think I'm saying that I I
know the language but the there's
conflicting language in my view as one
attorney and I don't think the court has
ruled on something like this so those
were the two funding sources and minimum
local contribution is defined in the
bill guess what as representative luno
says it needs to be adjusted to fit with
current valuations which are
substantially higher after the this was
done preco it needs to be adjusted to
get it right but the bottom line goal
after this is all done is to get the
state contribution to the total $3.5
billion nut up to get the total
allocation of the 40% State 60% uh Lo
local to get it more fairly
distributed and to have an ironclad
transparent production of data that
allows people to say we have opportunity
gaps that we need to address
right great thank thank you very much
for the chance thank you for the chance
to sit with you oh great always always a
pleasure
bill so I got a question for you before
you hit the Horizon here um the the the
costing of this is built around the uh
average cost of a student here in the
state of New Hampshire is that
correct the costing of this is is built
around not the average cost of a of a
student it's built around what what
districts are currently spending how
they're spending it and how their
students what their student outcomes are
and then by looking at that data over a
10-year period the um the folks that we'
contracted with on the commission the
the um the researchers from the American
institutes for research um studied how
that spending tied into student outcomes
and they also uh they also looked at
what the student and the district
characteristics were for each of those
school districts because just like what
we were talking about earlier with
Manchester um uh there are there are
things that clearly Drive um costs for
uh for
educ the doe 25 form reflects expenses
of of all the
districts and would the exclusion where
we take out the cost tuition and
transportation that's separate that's
disaggregate from this whole thing so we
have the remaining
expenses would this be uh would would
the your formula Your Foundation program
here benefit from us better knowing what
expenses within the doe 25 form are
absolutely necessary to fill an adequate
education the academic side not all
those other expens which are nonrelated
to the program and you know I've
mentioned it before why are we putting
the expense of of the the marching B
marching band into that sheet can we
take that stuff out and then find out
what the real average cost is so so just
to be clear we're not putting the
marching band or the football team into
that sheet but I think you could
probably ask superintendant across the
state and they'd say and and you'd ask
them why do you have a football team or
why do you have a robotics program um
and I think a lot of them would would
answer because that's what gets kids to
come through the door in the morning and
it's so that that that alone keeping
kids engaged having signed that that
that contract saying that that you will
be there during the school day um and
that's what makes you eligible for to
practice and to play for a lot of kids
that's a um that's a critical um part of
their education
and we hear it all the time at at I'm
not meln I'm not a big um college
football um you know Watcher but they
talk about how how football saved them
football got them through their
education I'm not a football player but
uh and I never thought I'd be sitting
here you know in the State House talking
about why football is so important I'm
picking an extreme example on this
notice I'm not saying turf field I'm not
saying things like like that but a lot
of these programs are part of the um of
the K12 experience whether it's early
enrichment programs whether it's um um
um uh uh U inter Scholastic um organized
Sports at the JV and high school level
at the middle school level uh uh these
are all part I think of the of the they
tie right in with the um with the the
the core elements in 193 e2a currently
for for you know Wellness education
things like that they're certainly
consistent with um with that are there
some expenses that districts take on
that don't result in um or that don't
drive student outcomes sure absolutely
and um when uh when the when the when
the commission researchers did the work
those amounts were discounted out and
and they were taken out through through
an efficiency so so I'm just follow up
tonight I don't want to hog up here but
so we have specific inputs our formula
right now which states these are the the
areas which are necessary to fulfill Our
obligation Alan adquate education why
can't those inputs be also put into the
back end of the formula you're talking
about where when I'm looking for a
certified math teacher I'm not looking
for a certified may maybe that can also
do football because it's a separate
stype and a separate contract than the
contract to
teach what I I'm just concerned that you
know some
some when I I look at Keem for example
right now they'll think well maybe we'll
have a hockey program over there maybe
that'll attract kids to the
Keen system which they're looking at but
that's not going to contribute to the
music program the fine music program and
fine theater programs that they are
known for or their teacher prep programs
which they're well known for so I'm I'm
concerned that and and I'll be right out
front right now I concern support much
of what came out of that report however
I do not like the aspect of costing this
thing at a certain cost based upon that
Doe 25 form which is not even audited by
all districts that you're receiving the
doe and we're taking that number and
saying that's what it costs to educate a
kid and um I think if we could take out
and put in the the components which
contribute to adequacy then I'd be with
it so so I I agree with you that that I
think the components that contribute for
adequacy need to uh need to be in
1932a and and um and 1586 does amend
those out and I think that those core
those core um elements of adequacy do
need to be contained in there we just
added personal financial literacy and
and um um and I think did we add
computer literacy last year yes as well
coup that that both those along with
along with those other elements U need
to remain remain in there so I think
there is the ability to do a hybrid uh
uh approach to how you define adequacy
but having that tight relationship
between accountability and adequacy in
terms of student performance this is
what I've heard ever since my first year
on the education committee where where
where everybody wants to know how our
students are doing and and what can we
do to to to make sure that uh that that
student performance student outcomes are
strong in each of our districts if we're
not um if we're not measuring that and
well we are measuring that through
through you know standardized testing
but also adding graduation rates adding
attendance rates but and have that in
have that feedback loop integral to the
accountability going right back to the
the um the adequate education as long as
the costing of that of an adequate
education is based on the definition of
an adequate education and the feedback
loop um ties back to that then I think
we've got a good integrated system that
can be measured monitor monitored and um
and and have the element that that
representative dry was saying how can
the department make sure that it can
help these districts uh improve their
student outcomes and before you leave
can you please explain how the weighted
formulas within all this work you know
because you have certain categories in
your blue book there I don't Bill's got
a head out so okay yeah so hitting the
road okay yeah why why don't we why
don't we let let attorney ardinger go
with with our deep thanks thank you this
is such an important issue for the state
ATT uh representative lad the the the
issues you're talking about the the one
thing I hear in it is I I think what
this bill does in one part is respect
local governance and local control first
and so it allows because nothing if you
look at your communities yeah main
Street's really important institutions
like religious institutions are
important to building Community um you
know youth baseball and hockey and other
activity programs YMCA is important to
communities but perhaps nothing's more
important to building Community than our
common schools our Public Schools what
you're doing is so important and I I
promise you I I want it to the extent
you guys will have me I want to
participate in it try and join you in
that effort I would just say that the
one thing I would urge you to be you
don't ever want to be so prescriptive in
my view just one person Not Elected I
was one time not now is is to be so so
prescriptive that your local governance
system can't have a good debate over
whether the Strings
program is something that really adds to
the student achievement and and I think
Dave's your comments were like this or
or the football program or the AP
programs you got to let those
superintendents those administrators
those teachers those parents battle it
out a little bit locally and yes every
District's going to make different
valuations decisions but through that
process as long as the state has the
data we can make sure that none of those
decisions are undermining the state's
Duty under Claremont one to guarantee
that every kid has a fair Shake thank so
thank you sorry thank you thank
you so you want to talk about the um the
weights so let's um let's go to the
bill and let's um actually uh we get to
the weights after the first two pages um
do you want me to just start right well
just just go into it just spend spend it
is a it's a new component which
we haven't built our previous program on
well there it's it's a new component but
it looks very similar actually so but
how we go about calculating those
weights is is actually based on evidence
as as opposed to a little B we did have
certain weights for example an f&r in
the 2008
model uh on the fiscal capacity um it
got to the point where if you had over
40 48% of the kids which were free
reduced meals you got a double in terms
of the
$3,456 you got close to Seven Grand uh
on top of your base cost
that that really certainly would help a
town like yours um I'm also concern at
that time when we were doing that did
the achievement scores look any
different than they are now that was
more money being put to these districts
but see and and so when a when a when a
district and and actually newport's sort
of a great example of this and in
Manchester is a good example of this too
um when a when a district works as hard
as they
can to to fund their local school budget
but they can't get there they can't
address the needs that uh that the
school has we heard about the needs that
that there are up in Newport um and I
mean it was it was uh I hadn't even
realized that and I use Newport as an
example all the time um but when when
when Newport which I think has the
highest or second highest local
education property tax rate can't hit a
budget number anywhere close to what I
mean to what other districts in the area
in New Hampshire throughout New
Hampshire are getting and they're and
they're working super hard to get there
then you know something's wrong with the
uh with the way that we're we're funding
schools and and I think the other thing
you need to that that represent lad that
you that you talk about here is that
when when we look at the uh the weights
the weights aren't
grants currently the weights that we
have in our funding
formula that's State Grant do
right that defines the cost of an
adequate education and the State dollars
come in as the first dollars to fund
that adequate education what we're doing
with 15 in
1586 as as opposed to using the formula
for funding it's used for costing so now
we're costing inadequate education in
terms of what district superintendent
would look at and say yeah that's pretty
CL that's pretty close to um to what it
would cost to uh to put on an adequate
education here in Manchester here in
Pittsfield here in Newport in Claremont
H Berlin wherever you happen uh happen
to be and I think you know Jen Gillis in
Manchester superintendent Manchester
would would probably look at could
probably look at um at hopkinson's
budget and say well even though if we
scaled it up based on the number of
students that's not the cost of an
adequate education in New Hampshire
because Hopkin doesn't have very many
elll you know English language Learners
um uh in our district we hopkington has
about a thousand kids in our district
Manchester has a thousand homeless kids
in their District so I mean the
challenges are completely different and
so so so the the the the the costing
formula which which begins on page
four uh is is is based on the experience
that all of these districts have had
what the unique student characteristics
are and in particular I mean you can you
can see right um starting with with line
eight um uh the number of St students so
ad everybody here knows adma we've gone
to admr now right so these are all
things that need to be changed in this
spill but free introduce price lunch
engl line 10 English language
learns also in our current in our
current funding formula that's those are
there um line 12 the number of students
in special education services um
representative lad talked about maybe
breaking that out into three
classifications I think that makes a lot
of sense and we can figure out what the
weights would be in order to uh to
determine that and then um um the um uh
line 14 and then the group of lines
below that size of the district and
there's different different weights um
according to that now once you've gone
the size of the district does that take
into account to the number of kids which
are the size of District some districts
are k through eight y uh so does that
take is there a funding mechanism there
a wait for the the uh grade levels does
down in aliance 26 and 28 yeah um you
have grade level uh funding and that all
gets built into this so all of this is
aggregated to come up to a foundation
operate opportunity budget the cost for
the school district to educate all of
its students to to a Statewide average
out so it's calibrated based based on
that uh it should be re-calibrated every
six years in the bill it says no no less
frequently than every 10 years thinking
now it should be done every six years to
recalculate that represent casan um
while you're in that part of the bill my
question was about line
29 where this bill has the universal
base Foundation opportunity cost should
equal
651 that that's considered the
base so should that change based on the
recent conval decision on what judge
ruoff recommended as a minimum that's a
great question represent Cas scen um I
would I would say that well let me say
how
$65,000 I'm $6,500 was arrived at was
was through the work that that we did
with the um with Drew ainson and Bruce
Baker at uh at air and basically
$6,500 was what was left over after you
take out all of these other components
for you to do special education English
language learner size of school grade
range stuff like that so uh very much I
think in line with with with what um uh
with what we heard yesterday in one of
the bills this is the cost for the
imaginary student that doesn't even walk
through a school door because doesn't
have size the school and all all that in
there so this it's it's the cost of a
student that doesn't really exist um uh
should it be adjusted
I think 6500 is actually very consistent
because this number does not include
Transportation the
7400 uh does include Transportation it's
$1,400 so so the um the conv Val base
less transportation is
$6,000 the um the
6501 and I and and I'm sorry to jump
ahead but if you turn to the next page
um the bill so down at the bottom on
lines 28 through
36 um has a um has
a sure I'm on the right section here
yeah um has a transition period so we
don't bring it in at a 100% in the first
year um uh back when this bill was
originally written it was we were
looking at a 7-year transition period uh
I would like to propose a 5-year
transition period where we begin the
first
year at 80% of the 6501 and everything
is built all the weights are all built
off the the the base number
um as opposed to being uh direct dollars
it's a it's a multiplier on the base so
so you'd see ABC and
D at the bottom of page five go from 80%
to 85% 90% 95% and then online 36 for
fiscal year 2030 and later 100% so it'
be a has there been a spreadsheet
developed for this what's that has there
been we're working with Mark on that
right now has he given us a well he'll
be this afternoon have we got a timeline
when that might be available U we can
talk with Mark about that but but it
he's he's very he's he's still work
tweaking some things he's got some
things that uh that he talked about that
that I mean Mark comes from the LBA
School of spread spr sheet design which
means you've got to be down to the penny
accurate and um and I and I said well
Mark for some of these things I'd be I'd
be happy you know with the Barn Door
sort of accuracy knowing that we're
really close so that from a policy
perspective we can discuss these things
I think he wants to get down to the
penny which I appreciate his uh his his
level of diligence on on that um but
let's let's talk with him about that
this afternoon that's on the docket and
I and I've talked with him about some of
these uh changes mhm um and we can get
into to to some more
let's if it's all right I I'd like to
sort of keep going and and and you know
we've talked about how we build out the
foundation opportunity budget based on
the
65 6501 base and then these multipliers
to that base for the different uh
student and District characteristics
that still has not resulted in a dollar
of State funds going to anybody this is
just determining the foundation
opportunity budget what a district
should
spend to educate all of its students to
a Statewide average outcome it's a
strong outcome nationally a strong
outcome
um the the next page um page
six but I want to make sure
in in SE in section six so I'm looking
page six line
17 this is where the the uh the policy
on on state Grant so now we're talking
about the um the the funding mechanism
and we talked about how how when you
take this Foundation opportunity budget
and let's just let's just pick a number
for um for
Hopkinson cuz I know Hopkin let's pick
the number for Hopkin that the
foundation opportunity budget came out
at $20 million we got 1,000 kids and
it's not based on a Statewide average
but all the differentiating factors all
that stuff came out to be $20
million um the um the first the first
dollars to fund that $2 million budget
come from section 6 and um and Roman 2
down on starting on line 29 um and 30
where you can see five $5 per thousand
of equalized assess valuation well that
was based on a long time ago back when
Statewide we had a 220 um um you $220
billion Statewide valuation we now have
a $340 billion Statewide valuation so
the this this local minimum contribution
that that attorney ardinger was talking
about um that would I think we need to
recalculate how that's done based on
based on uh a an a Statewide share
fiscal policy a Statewide share um of
for for State funding of public um
Public Schools so whether that's going
to be 41 42 50% something like that you
calculate what that is and then based on
a Statewide basis you calculate that
local minimum contribution
um based on that Statewide share divided
by the the total property tax base in
the I'm sure I'm oversimplifying I don't
know if uh if there's any folks from Dr
here no they'll be here they so I'm I'm
oversimplifying but I think for the
example here you know if the Statewide
share was let's say
42% of of our current um total K total
current K12 expense attorney AR you said
$3.4
billion right I think he said that I
mean I'm really close um uh 42% would be
about
1.3 billion dollar currently we
spend
1.06
billion I think I'm really close it's
close and um and so at 42% goes from
1.06 to $1.3 billion so a $250 million
increase but that's only if we're at
100% remember we said starting at 80%
and phasing it in over five
years so I think we can we can come up
with a with a transition plan that
starts very close to where we are right
now and this is all stuff that we should
kick around but but that that um that
minimum local contribution becomes the
first dollars that go towards
hopkinton's $20 million Foundation
opportunity budget so if we just stuck
with the example here $5 per thousand
hopkinson's got an A uh
uh I think we've got a total valuation
of about a billion dollars so so um so
so $5 per th000 would generate $5
million
right am I doing the math right here
sounds good right billion dollar
valuation dollar per th000 yeah so
billion goes to a million times five
gives you $5 million the state Grant the
state Foundation opportunity budget
grant for Hopkinson I'm looking at my
ways and means and finance people to
would be $15
million and so hopkinson's
Hopkinson would then I mean that that's
all they need to
spend is the $5 is that mandatory that
local minimum contribution towards their
Foundation opportunity budget if they
wanted to spend more than that they
could and they can debate the heck out
of this on the floor of school district
meeting um it would make for a great
debate too because the state says you
only need to spend this why do you want
all this extra stuff and and there's
probably going to be towns I'm sure
they're going to say hey we want some
extra stuff too and and maybe they'll do
that but but for a lot of communities
many many communities certainly
Claremont Pittsfield and Berlin um their
budgets in Manchester not even close to
the foundation opportunity budget and
when when Mark runs the sheets and I
said we'd eventually be getting into the
town by towns fact I'm really glad we're
having this conversation without having
the town by towns first because we can
really talk about this
as in about how it
works um and then and then see it
manifest when when Mark has the uh the
spreadsheets done but um but that's
basically how the how the how the
costing formula Works where we talked
about on the prior page with the weights
and the Bas and how the funding um
portion works with the local minimum
contribution and the State comes in with
the grants and that's on the uh the next
page
um determine oh sorry that's the term of
of transition grants
um opportunity
contribution oh so the the
um the State Grant
isation I promise you it's in here it's
basically calculated as the difference
between the local contribution and the
foundation opportunity bu
um uh one of the other things that um
that um attorney arer talked about was
the determination of transition grants
so that's on the next page at page seven
so where um where uh where districts may
be seeing uh less from the state um
maybe due to uh loss of excess
swept that that that there are TR tax
transition grants over a five-year
period that phases that in so that they
don't see any shock in year one um so
100% of the difference in year 1 80% in
year two and that tapers over a if you
recall what what is the amount of excess
is it roughly around 27 million
something like that yeah is that where
we are said 29 million y
35 it's it's right yeah but you're
you're right in the ballp part so on
that yeah okay and
um and so if we want to sort of proceed
through through the bill a dayve yeah
the uh determination of State Foundation
opportunity grants is at page
five line 8 you you are trying to find
that okay that's why I didn't see it
yeah and and it's basically it's the
budget netted out by
the the local minimum contribution
yeah so um thank thank you dick so lines
14 and 16 on page
five Grant shall be the adjusted annual
Foundation opportun budget for each
municipality reduced by B each Municipal
minimum Foundation budget
contribution as determined in in 41A
which is what we were what we had
skipped up to with the $5 per thousand
example um but like I said that that
needs to be that needs to be the
language there needs to be changed or
should be changed so that the the rate
would float given given a fiscal policy
share of whatever percentage should be
the the state state policy I think um
Bill aringer handed out a sheet
yesterday that had what all what
different states do Massachusetts New
Hampshire and others and um and um uh
obviously our our property valuations
change year to year and then and so a
local minimum contribution rate should
um should be reflective of of those
changes as opposed to having something
fixed uh in
statute yes represent dry thank you um
before we move on to the next part at
the top of page five it talks about uh
none of the funds
uh are used for any other purpose
including what not limited to making
payments to chartered Public Schools so
what happens to
them I think later on in this bill we
have a a section on it there's a study
to uh a chapter to to study how how this
could extend to chartered public schools
and I would also say that that it would
need to extend to um to how EFA programs
are are funded as well uh because this
this did not contemplate that um
um y so that's a pretty big missing
piece that's why it was put into as a
study okay it establishes a study
committee to um to examine how best to
do that given a foundation opportunity
budget uh framework okay thank
you okay casc yes uh just going a little
further past the transition Grant so we
you know when when the commission were
completed there was a time when with
arpa and car's act but that is n in void
now right um I don't know enough thanks
thanks for the question I have that
noted in here too okay that that so so
what Dr cascad is talking about is on
page seven lines 30 and 31 yes where the
transition grants would would come from
any remaining ARB cares act funds and uh
I I don't know to what extent any of
those are banked or I think they have to
be used by 2026 September 2024 I thought
they have be obligated okay yeah they
have to be obligated by September 2024
so um so that's that's that's something
that that you know we would need to we
would need to look at and what the
source of funds the source of funds
could be the education trust fund
M yeah you'd have to change that I mean
we could when are the uh it I thought
there had be spent by the 20 FY 26 yeah
SP but obligated by September 2024
yeah yeah and so so you know like with
everything there's you know you know
wherever you take air out of the balloon
you know it's it's going to get smaller
and uh and so you know if
um if for instance you wanted to to have
more of a remainder in the education
trust fund to support tax transition
grants you could slow down the
transition of of the foundation
opportunity plan rather than over 5
years starting at 80% maybe it's over
over you know 7 years starting at 70% or
something like that but then those
transition grants are going to have to
go greater because you're starting with
a lower number uh to begin with u so it
it's you know those are those are some
competing things that we would need to
iron out yes
question how does this work with
Cooperative school districts so there's
section on
cooperatives let me get to it
here yeah bottom of
seven okay
and so the um the I think the idea here
is is very similar to um to how our how
how municipalities currently receive
funding for the school districts where
they where they participate and so the
the funding through the foundation
opportunity budget is still done at the
M
municipality level so remember you've
got costing which is the foundation
opportunity budget and then you've got
funding which which is basically by
municipality and um and
there different co-ops have I think
different agreements in terms of share
and so it would have to follow th that
that that
share
yeah yes yes so on a very fundamental
basis I just want to make sure I
understand um at least structural how
the revenues would be raised say that
again I'm sorry I want to understand
structurally how the revenues would be
raised if if I'm following
this every Community regardless of
whether it's got a district of its own
or it's in a Cooperative School District
would be responsible for assessing $5
per thousand value to real
property and that would be the basic
contribution there'd be the calculated
uh model budget the state would pick up
the balance uh to that regardless of
what the for example um articles of
agreement for Cooperative District
indicate and then uh locally but now in
the case of a of a re of a school
district the collective group of towns
comprising that school district would
have their Collective debate about
whether they wanted to authoriz spending
beyond that and then they would allocate
that burden according to their article
of agreement which would roll back into
a further charge against local education
tax is that more or less correct I I
think you've without getting at all into
the question of how the state raises its
portion sure I think you've summed it up
but the local Ed tax would be a
combination of a $5 base plus whatever
shakes out of a local
districtwide um resolution on extra
spending right
okay that that's absolutely correct the
only caveat I would say is the $5 base
obviously was using three-year-old data
that's that would you know calculating
that local minimum contribution rate
would uh would would be recalculated
based on on what uh what we come down
for as a state
share and total valuation across the
state yeah I okay that's that's an
interesting clarification obviously
costs are a moving Target and how you
raise it may therefore be a moving
Target but in an Ideal
World we would have an understanding
that a certain portion of a um property
owner's value could be dedicated to any
purpose in this case local education and
that $5 is that reasonable amount and as
property
values shift or rise then that allows
for more funds to be raised but one of
the fundamental problems we have and and
we want to get away from that in this
well one of the things I think that is
most fundamentally flawed in the New
Hampshire Revenue model is that uh we
just reverse engineer from our costs to
How Deeply we're going to burden real
estate tax and the more we can get away
from that in this Bild the better we
would be do you see what I'm saying it
would be great have a $5 and just fix it
forever yeah let real estate values
fluctuate or rise but but but that's a
percentage of a valuation and in an
ideal world that would be locked into
eternity um I I I hear what you're
saying and and I I'm really here to
present not debate but we're in sort of
like a work group type situation when
when $5 was calculated and you know
working with with dick GES and Mel and
and Bill uh on this uh it was uh 2020 or
2021 and I think we had Statewide
property values of $220 billion so um uh
so you know
five and and you know let me just pick
on Hopkinson we had hopkinson's
valuation was around
$750 uh million so $5 raised
um $3.8 million something something like
that um $5 today in Hopkinton raises $5
million because property values have
gone way up when um when you've got um
select boards and school boards that are
developing budgets uh they're not devel
developing those budgets based on a
fixed um property tax rate the property
tax rate adjusts to that budget so if
valuations go up that property tax rate
comes down and and um and I guess what
I'm what I'm what I'm sort of saying in
in this is that is that in the three
years since we originally drafted this
uh I I think you know when when when
looking at how how we prescribe $5 per
thousand that that that would put um a
very heavy burden on on um on on on tax
property taxpayers given a sub a
significant rise up in property
valuation and that maybe that that tax
rate should come down um uh in order to
raise the same amount of local
contribution dollars towards that
Foundation opportunity budget and and um
followup question the drra has suggested
way do that so are we going to be able
to remodel that and and see how it
shakes out absolutely in these coming
weeks before February 15th thank you
that's why you're on this committee y
yeah and we'll and and and Terry we'll
remodel that um using using you know
current the latest Dr valuation numbers
so yes GES I just wanted to note because
it hasn't been said that
um the minimum Foundation budget
contribution
is $5 per thousand
or it is the municipality's adjusted
annual Foundation opportunity budget I
was trying to say this for my friend
over there who's engaged in a lively
conversation with a
seatmate let me try
again the uh I wanted everybody to note
that um when we say $5 per thousand or
I'll say x per thousand because that's
going to change um as the amount that's
going to be raised locally it's going to
be less than that for
municipalities we could name them um
that are currently raising more and
would be raising under this new
Arrangement more than the foundation
opportunity budget they only have to
raise up to that budget so it might be
4% to to use the five as the starting
point and so forth that's an important
difference thank you thank you
represent okay we're getting pretty
close to the time we should take a break
because we're gonna have people walking
in here at one o'clock oh wait the
second part we're at 12:15 right
now um so we some more right there on
that you know we we've really gone
through the um the the obviously there's
a whole section on accountability yeah
um you know I think we've described it
as a as a as a tight feedback loop to
the definition of an adequate education
and the funding of that adequate
education so um
so certainly take a look at at that um I
I noted um representative Le's um
suggestions yesterday about having it
apply not just to schools that were
underperforming but to all schools and I
think that's a very reasonable approach
for the Department to make sure that all
schools are um are meeting that um that
uh uh that student outcome Benchmark um
and then the the last part of the bill
is um is the uh swept reform we talked
about that yesterday in
1686 uh 1686 1686 it's very similar to
the swep or form in 1686 with the
exception that while all of the
Statewide property tax is collected
locally 100% of it is remitted to the to
the uh to the State Treasury and um and
the foundation opportunity grants that
that U municipalities are entitled to
will come directly back to that
municipality from the um from the state
treasury so there's no like retained
swept or or anything like that that
eliminates the negative tax rate dilemma
with respect to um uh retained uh excess
swept um the other thing beyond that and
this is getting right to the tail end
the bill so won't um you know we
can we've talked about it with other
bills um is uh is an expanded low and
moderate property ta low and moderate
income property tax relief fund so that
increase currently the the draw on that
is I think we heard yesterday $1.6
million a year um we would intend to
fund that at a at a level of $25 million
per year and provide property tax relief
not to all property taxes that live in a
certain zip code whether they need it or
not um but but property tax relief to
any property taxpayer living in any
municipality anywhere in the state that
that um qualifies under certain criteria
income criteria and and I think there's
some other criteria in there and that's
that's for for our friends from Ways and
Means I think they saw that in House
Bill 56 569 569 um from representative
Ames uh has those two pieces um
identical there may be some little tweak
differences that that we could align
with that but um but um anyway that's
all I got thank you any further
questions from the committee right now
to I think we're ready for
lunch so I think we're going to break
right now and we'll come back at
1:00 yes
here no we were just going to get
through the Dr and the doe doing the
thing and then we'll some wrap up
discussion ourselves then we're out of
here
so 1 2:30 maybe 2:30 3 3
o' yeah I think
that e
my wife said you know I've been used to
having for supper whenever I get home
or but then I
always
e
e e
afternoon por today we have both the
Department of Revenue Administration and
doe here to answer any questions which
we may have and to also give us maybe
some remarks as they see it in regard to
uh any of the four bills which we have
here I'd like to have them introduce
themselves right now we have to my right
Mark manganello with the Department of
Education Bureau of school Finance thank
you and to my left Bruce can supervisor
of the municipal Bureau at Department of
Revenue Keen May qualy council
department of revenue thank you and
welcome
back had a
discuss pH okay yeah we had a discussion
early this morning on on 1586 a brief
discussion and um there were some
questions that came out of that and also
uh we have not got into a discussion yet
on the other other bills which are
dealing with the uh base cost um uh
increase that's basically uh a change
just in in a costing amount and in the
um special ed uh differentiated a that's
also a change in the costing
amount uh swep we we um have discussed
it in conjunction with
1586 so right now um did we flip the
coin and see who's going to start
together are you going to still do it
collap
together interact with each other Dr and
doe yep I thought you're going to sit
together but
no there must be something between these
two departments um so
uh in regard to 1586 Mark
M do you have some um uh insights for us
in regard to 1586 or some areas where
maybe there have to be some
modifications or changes Etc yeah
there's um so obviously as uh some of
you might remember from two years ago it
was 1680 um so the dates have been
updated so um I think I uh verbally told
the committee some of the technical
errors but I think I need to kind of get
those more in writing um so that they
can be codified um so some of the
technical errors still exist some of
them are um kind of the ones we're used
to seeing an admr adma um uh map um some
of the ones you've already discussed uh
relative to how IT addresses um efas and
Charter Schools um this is just again
I'll put this in writing at some point
but it it kind of um a technical error
with it um it sort of puts them in limbo
and then defunds them why they're in
limbo um so if you're um you want to
have a position if the subcommittee
wants to have a position on the EFA
program and charter school program
meaning if you want to put them sort of
in limbo and then defund them then
that's what the bill does as introduced
I don't think that was the intent I
think the not the intent the intent was
to study them um so that is currently
just a technical issue with the bill as
introduced um you were discussing the
ARP money uh my understanding is that
money is likely unavailable and likely
already is out the door and needs to be
out the door very quickly um so that's
again just a technical issue where that
bill is looking to seek to use those
funds and those funds essentially don't
exist um so so you're going quickly here
yep uh so the transition
to uh put the 158
uh into full speed we need some of that
money to do that correct to the the
intent as introduced was to use federal
funds to pay for that transition
correct but um and as you discussed as I
was watching guys on YouTube um you
could draw that from the Surplus the
Surplus is I mean this is a now a ways
and means and finance decision obviously
um but the alternative would be to fund
basically you're funding it from the
education trust fund would by default
and yeah you were discussing that um but
that's so the the Essa not the Essa
sorry the arp arp issue um EFA Charter
School issue um that's some housekeeping
um the admr that's very easy
housekeeping uh the other thing
representative luno and I were chatting
and representative luno told the
committee the bill is introduced
basically doesn't do what it's supposed
to do and it's because of our growth and
property values so repres pres luno and
I ran um I have some numbers I'm not
really confident to send them out like
in a spreadsheet and I don't want to go
town by town until we're ready to
actually kind of really get into the
weeds um but the bill as currently
written and is introduced would decrease
school funding by hundreds of millions
of dollars and the reason that is is
because of our property growth so you
have the foundation opportunity budget
that's up here it's it's hitting a
benchmark uh a standard to provide a
foundation opportunity budget and then
you immediately apply that $5 tax rate
and since that $5 tax rate against our
really robust property growth brings in
so much money less State money goes out
the door as introduced so representative
luno and I overheard I was watching uh
the committee um the percent of State
share is a way we could do that I have
to that that would be an easy fix or an
easy way I just have to think about it a
little
bit but um not doing that analysis
but just trying to take the original
intent and bring that property tax rate
to a number that achieves the same
results with the new property growth if
I dropped it down to $3 per
5,000 um and did nothing else it would
reduce in a total net funding of less
than $18 million so basically a less 18
$18 million in state money money would
go uh less 18 million uh less would go
out the door compared
to
yeah um so the other thing represent of
luno and I discussed and
and uh you know if the objective is to
keep it relatively net neutral then
that's not exactly net neutral you know
$18 million out of a $3.5 billion
economy is uh you'd say rounding ER but
um if you want to increase it more you
could change modifications like you
could take that Universal base Aid
amount and make it the conval
number and running that really quickly
that would result in $200 million more
in state funding for schools so there's
a lot of variables to Tinker with um I
just sort of need I probably need to
work with representative luno if it's
what the committee is looking to do is
to get that bill in a position to be
ready to see spreadsheets I probably
need to work with representative luno to
get those V uh all the variables where
they need to be and hit what the
committee is interested in looking at um
and then I can produce those
spreadsheets Mr
yes you talk fast and I'm trying to keep
notes um can you go over once again
about the efas and Charter Schools the
the atttention of the bill and then the
solution for it was the the bill has
introduced repeals the section of law we
use to fund efas meaning to to determine
the grant amount and it repeals half of
the section of law which is
adequacy sorry it repeals adequacy as we
know it and replaces it inadequacy
currently that calculation of the grant
is what funds efas in its entirety um
and it does also what funds basically
half of what Charter Schools receive um
so that's a technical fix that would
need to be made which would if you want
to keep current law as is you could
say you could say uh um you basically
have to re get rid of out see where it
exists but then also probably find a new
home for it I mean that's just what the
bill would that's what the amendment
would have to look like okay um to the
bill to keep efas and Charters funded at
their current levels um so so just a
just I thought on I think that's a very
important um uh Point representative dry
uh and uhu and not something that we
wanted to to see drop but when we when
we uh reenacted in the bill uh what is
it 1984a mhm is that 198 that that's
adequacy yeah yeah yeah and U and
currently both the the charter um
statute and the efh statute both refer
to 194
1984a uh we could put we could put
something into Charter or or EFA yeah
and then the other one whichever the
other one is refer to that that would be
that would be one way to to to a
technical fix yeah yeah and it would it
would basically look like our current
one 98 um 4A okay and what was the study
committee that you were talking about
for that and there's a study committee
in there to consider in the long ter in
the long term how to how to fund uh
Charters and efas and it's in the I
think it's at the back of the um the uh
1586 okay so just to be clear then then
if they do the technical fix then efas
and Charter Schools still stay funded
while they're studied okay absolutely
absolutely stay funded
and and stay funded the same way they've
been they are funded okay thank you
yeah if you're working with uh represent
luno to try and get a spreadsheet is
there kind a time frame in which that
might be available to this subcommittee
so so doing one fiscal year um not that
hard I mean it just as matter as what's
the target what's the you know it's $200
million that is that the target we're
going for negative $18 million is that
the target we're going for so so um and
so
there's there's a couple things I want
to talk with you about that and and I
think your your suggestion of using the
conell number makes a lot of sense but
but I'm also thinking we talked about
this earlier having a 5year phase in
yeah and so that's the that's the the
tougher challenge with that I think
doing a fiscal year analysis for one
spreadsheet I've done that before and I
can do that again um and we're just
working some couple variables and I
think representative Luna and have
chatted about some of the variables that
he thinks needs to move um doing a 5year
analysis a little bit trickier but um I
would want to have one an one year
analysis that the committee is kind of
interested in before I start doing you
know multiple more
spreadsheets thank thank you Mark thanks
for are there any other technical
aspects that you see that need
correcting within the
bill uh
the I believe that's I believe that's it
uh one one thing and that we debated
this um or discussed this uh two years
ago uh The
Cooperative uh sorry no the school
district size portion I'm that might
need a little bit more study I don't
know if I'm doing
it it it's it's it probably works I just
don't know if it works as the 2020
commission intended um it I actually I I
don't I don't know if it's worth going
down that rabbit hole but I but I have a
system in place to try to
this is to so works in the bill this is
to eliminate the cliff effect yeah as as
you're going so um so we talked about
this couple years ago too and it's I I
don't think from a from a modeling
standpoint it's it
um it's a fairly minor it yeah so the
only thing I'm doing that potentially
doesn't this is now again really
technical in the weeds here um we
discussed this two years
ago when you take an admr and an adma
essentially a student is a student but
you have to pick a measurement in order
to put it into a data set and run it
through an algorithm so I am using admr
as the data point yes and so that might
not have been the intent of the 2020
commission
but converting an adma to an admr or
saying they're equivalent at the end of
the day isn't I don't think a big deal
um but you do have to Define what
measurement for student you want to use
and so that's a that's a potential
rabbit hole we could go down I I I I
don't um it's all it's up to the sponsor
as far as or the committee if they want
to go down we'd move to an admr
approach I mean Mr chairman well admr is
what we want to use that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah just as a non-education
Committee Member is that average daily
membership attendance versus residence
or what is it okay thank you that that's
corrected and and residence is how we
fund because we fund it based on which
school district is responsible for
paying for the education attendance is
where they attend school um sometime
they're the same student or same
measurement um a lot of times they're
not or a good amount of
times so when you're trying to Define
this from a policy perspective uh this
particular this weighted
formula uh in terms of size of
school either
represent luno can you please refresh my
mind you know I I know it I can
understand that the um the cost that it
cost for example very small
school because they don't have the
population in the school of
students but they have to re by our
requirements provide certain programs so
that efficiency of scale costing to the
scale of what they've got there it seem
it's more for the it's just like it
costs more to run uh White Mountain
Community College that does a larger
Community College down here simply
because of scale of numbers but they
require providing all these courses that
are required for a gen Ed um so uh we
have that and there's also the that
relationship with whether it's an
elementary school a middle school or a
high school where a high school has to
have certain facilities and
programs which require
specialization chemistry for example uh
verse uh teaching one how to read in a
classroom in a Grade School so how are
we accounting for all that within this
model so so that's on page four line 16
through 23 I'm sorry 24 page four page
four line 16- 24 where the size of the
school varying between one and 2,000 or
over 2,000 one one student to over 2,000
students would receive a different
waiting
Factor where the the um
uh where the smallest have a little bit
higher weights associated with them
going down to over 2,000 there's no
additional
weight and it's hard to it's hard to
read this from the looking at the the
weight themselves because the weights
are defined as a line that would go
between um so looking at the first one
between 1 and 200 it would be a a
decreasing um a a a a negative sloping
line and that negative slope is is
defined as um you know y = mx+b so so
you know M you know the the formula for
a slope Bri mhm that's what you're
looking at here
0.451 multiplied by adma adma would be
the xais the weight would be the Y AIS
and B would be the Y intercept so yeah I
mean I love this right I mean this is
and The Intercept is higher for smaller
smaller districts
yeah so it's going to be more
advantageous for smaller schools um
based on the based on the starting from
a higher point and then going down as
you get more
students yes go ahead
um back again to question of Co-op or
school districts um my Co-op um each of
the um small towns have one or two
elementary schools in their town but
there's one Regional Middle School one
Regional High School so how do you work
that for each individual town in their
budget because they you know they've got
a certain population within the middle
school and within the high school but
it's not the total number in the high
school
school right but they still have a a
number of students that are at the
middle school or high school that uh
that are attending so they get a they
get a share uh the the they have their
local share and their state share right
so but for those students right do you
have to adjust this to say that not the
size of the school
district but the population in some
cases well I see what you're saying of
the students going to that Regional
School and that's what we debated I
think we had this exact conversation two
years ago and it's so it's sort of um we
we got hung up here two years ago um so
to is we're talking about at the actual
school um or grade level uh grade level
basically what what kind quasi factor in
uh a middle school versus High School
Etc um but no when the way I'm reading
this bill is um it's not about school
it's about school district so Governor
Wentworth in its entirety is just a
school district with x amount of
students and it it gets plot it's get
plotted on here um it doesn't uh it
doesn't factor in whether you have a
high school or local elementary schools
it just looks at Governor wwor as a
district in its entirety um that's how
this section of the bill works
so it would not um if it was done at the
school
level and if it was how do you work it
for um wolfboro has two elementary
schools but they're not their own
District yes so they're so wolfboro is
not considered uh oh what I'm doing is
I'm looking at the students from that
live in wolfboro the way the formula
works the students who live inm yes I'm
looking at the admr so I'm taking the
students that live in wolfboro say
there's 50 and I'm going well there are
part of Governor Wentworth Governor
Wentworth is is is um I don't know how
many admr for governor WTH is but
whatever it is whatever it plots on this
these buckets um I'm treating them all
I'm adding them all is
that um is that what you're doing today
with the current um um state adequacy
grants it's always admr and it's always
yeah so it's the same it's the same as
what you're doing now under the the yeah
the only thing difference when in this
bill versus what we do currently is we
never um there's no current weight or
metric that looks at school district
it's purely mun when we're doing the
current formula this one uh requires a
little
crosswalking taking the mmun data and
and and bringing it to the school
district level um and then factoring a
weight so so that's a good point though
that that maybe we should make that
clear that the um that the
a in line 16 through through 24 I'm
sorry 16 through
26 let me go all the way down to 16
through 28 is not the admr in the in the
municipality but it's the admr of the
district
right so because is that different than
the admr that would be used on
line8 uh
pre-introduced price lunch would be
different view of admr
yeah yeah so you could also have so what
what it created some challenges for me
when I first had to put this together
was split districts are a challenge um
so I had to a portion those out um so I
still have to aor split districts are a
whole other animal as far as
um the town of wear has let's say they
have 100 students um uh 50 of those
students could be through going to the k
to weight where district and they get a
different weight and then 50 other
students could be going to John stock
and they get a different weight so I'm
splitting those out currently and that's
how I'm reading this this
bill but yeah it's a little it's it's
Unique in a sense it's not how we um we
in the current law we always stick
within the world of mun and we never
look at school district but in this bill
we are looking at school district
information and bringing it down to the
mun level um looking at students
essentially and where they attend what
school district they belong to um and
and since it's admr it shouldn't make a
difference for Town tuition oh correct
yeah that and that's the key thing when
youever you talk about adma admr admr is
how our current systems designed so if
you ever switch to an if you ever
decided to switch to an adma funding
model and mess up every tuition
agreement in the state um so yeah
keeping an admr keeps that tuition stuff
clean that would be your desire for the
legis uh you know I think I think um I
don't do tuition agreements I think
every school district would be uh
admr keeps it pretty pretty clean yeah
keep it at admr there's a lot of schools
tuition right and we don't want to mess
that
up okay other other
uh questions regarding that that you
might have for Mark at this time or you
want to get in some of the tax stuff
yeah uh the the one thing I'll say just
um because there was a lot of testimony
about it uh U and this this was a good
segue probably into Bruce and and his
work but um the negative tax rate
conversation that we had yesterday um I
just was just it's always interesting
when we do see a negative tax rate
because there's negative negative tax
rates caused by swept um but I think
Windsor is an interesting example I just
wanted to use I don't know if it was
discussed yesterday um
Windsor um put a lot of appropriated a
lot of funding for their school district
because they thought they were going to
have more students that they were going
have to send tuition bills uh tuition
out um but then those they made an ER
and so they budgeted a lot of local
money um uh to fund their tuition bills
but then those students were never there
so they never had to pay those tuition
bills which resulted in them having to
give money back to the taxpayers which
resulted in a negative tax rate so it's
just like when we talk about examples of
negative tax rates um most of the
negative tax rates are caused by uh
essentially swept money that uh a tiny
school district can't use but there are
some instances like the town of Windsor
where they are actually educating
students um and they have excess money
coming in so that was just one
peculiarity that came up yesterday
during uh during the hearing
but we have a possibility that a
district May split up of a new found um
with Bridgewater going its own way gr
and Hein following along with them will
this impact that at all
this bill impact impacted District
splitting up way we're yeah anything
we're doing here that that deals with
this weighted formula right here um
would have imp fact impact new found no
so it wouldn't impact so adequacy always
admr always calculated at the Town level
um it would impact it would impact
um uh it would impact the um uh it
talking about this formula um what
school district they belong to so those
particular weights which is a section um
I think
there's I'll just give you some
context so when I tally up all the
weights currently in the in the bill
there's
432,000 weights and I take 40 432,000
weights and I uh multiply by the
universal base Aid um and that's how
this basically how the foundation
opportunity budget
Works
um so almost none of the weights would
be affected except for what we just
discussed you live in Bristol you attend
Newfound uh uh Newfound has x amount of
students when Bridgewater Hein and
groten are in right so now they're a
smaller School District so now they're
going to potentially get both
communities would potentially get more
weights this is just yeah you know just
the way it plays out because it's it
benefits smaller school districts um
well there you
just yeah so that that would be but but
again that's 41,000 weights that would
be kind of messed with out of
4 432,000 so it would it would have a an
impact but uh it would be I don't know
how much it would the magnitude of it I
can't really speak to yeah okay are
there any other questions for Mark right
now well let's swing it over to the
other side of the room here and and uh
were you listening this
morning no
okay we we we had uh some of the
questions uh uh represent luno why don't
you started out with some of the issues
that we did discuss and that we might
get some resolution from Dr now right so
so thank you Mr chair so um one of the
areas that that uh I talked that we we
talked about a little bit in the hall
yesterday was um find out do you uh by
the way do you have a copy of 1586
so I'm looking at page
six lines 29 through
33 and
specifically yeah lines 30 and 31 um
where it talks about $5 per thousand of
equalized assessed valuation of all
property tax will pursuant to 768 and
and um and I I I think from the from the
this is what we were talking about from
the time we drafted this bill three
years ago and we had $220 billion in
Statewide taxable property and now we've
got 340 billion I think if I'm
remembering the numbers I heard that
that $5 per thousand
um is is a substantially increased tax
burden due to the rise in property
valuations so so we're thinking that
that we may need to have a paragraph in
here that that allow that provides the
calculation of that tax rate per
thousand based on a a um you know if
we're if we're going with a fiscal
policy and you plug in whatever number
you want but the number that keeps
coming up um came up yesterday is a 42%
State share and a 58% local share of
the
total um uh
uh state and local cost so not the
federal part but the the $3.4 billion
yep I'm sort of finger in the wind close
so so it would
be it it so that F that number there on
line 30 is to be the local share
of that
$3.4 billion and if that's supposed to
be 58% of that then how do
you how do you calculate the tax rate
and it's probably a lot more complicated
than my simplistic way which is which
would be 58% of $3.4 billion divided by
the total Statewide property
valuation yeah you know something like
that I'm from a municipal Bureau dr's
perspective I think initially for us
it's going to be helpful to just review
right now very quickly the chronology of
setting a local school tax rate under
current law current conditions and then
compare that to what this bill is
attempting to do just to make sure that
we're first of all understanding the
flow through this bill of what needs to
happen okay
you move the microphone just a little
bit closer
possibly
certainly how's that yeah better yeah
and and and so so Bruce I think that's I
think that's that's good because the um
the the the tax rate that you would be
calculating would
be just as it says here um for each
municipality the amount that is the less
of and one would be
um x per thousand where X is based
on 58% of the $3.4
billion right or
or or up to the um the not to exceed the
foundation opportunity budget which is
defined elsewhere in here so there's a
ceiling to what that calculated tax rate
would be right in each
municipality I understand I think and
and then beyond that there could even be
a local education property tax should
the municipalities or the school
district vote to have something in
addition to the foundation operating
budget right this from three years ago
and again now the bill seems to have
some alterations to the way we at Dr
would understand setting the property
tax rate so if you will let's let's
Place ourselves right now in the midst
of a school district's budget work
they're getting ready for the hearings
and so forth um to the Department of
Revenue even though we might know
something because of the tax portal and
the fact that districts are entering
data so we're aware but right now
we're just awaiting results I'm going to
stop for a second and shift back to the
bill see if I have this right in the
future should this pass as written or at
least in terms of its
chronology Mark and and education would
have
calculated a uh Foundation
opportunity budget a number that the
school district would
know about earlier than right now into
the from the fall at it mentioned by no
uh there's a date November 1st is it in
other words education is going to
utilize the bills mechanics to come up
with a dollar amount School District
knows it must write an Appropriations
budget that is at least that large okay
I think is that would be a correct
reading of what the bill was trying to
accomplish at that point in time okay
okay from Dr 's perspective um we're on
the sidelines at that point if I'm
reading it correctly we don't have
anything to do Mark and his team can
literally take whatever the Bill's rate
is the legislation would tell him and
utilizing already prepared equalized
valuation numbers and the formula is
embedded in the in the legislation to
create that dollar amount that a
district would need to understand as it
goes through its bud budgeting process
and brings it out to uh a vote with the
the voters see I think that's that's a
little bit different I want to make sure
I I understand what you just said Bruce
so so the um the dep the Department of
Education would calculate the the sum of
all Foundation opportunity
budgets so that's the number that would
finger in the air approach $3.4 billion
doar or something like that based on
current current um
spending and and then the Department of
Revenue Administration
would use that
number and apply a a fiscal
policy multiplier to that and that would
be the the
58% the local share to the total number
not to the individual Foundation
opportunity budgets this would be novel
approach for Department of Revenue I
mean currently the school district acts
independently within the law in building
out a recommended budget or when I say
that I'm concentrating on Appropriations
yeah the S because the bill at times
mentions
spending and and that would be right
approved appropriation lead to spending
So currently if this bill was in
place I didn't know I couldn't see the
Department of Revenue was is doing
anything in this time frame other than
perhaps
observing whether when Mark would I say
Mark when education would prepare the
foundation opportunity the minimum that
a district must uh raise or I should say
appropriate we would be aware of it but
currently whatever a district decides to
budget in an appropriation we don't have
a say about that we don't intervene so
that would be n
for us to at that point as the budget
comes into being in say right now in
January it's getting ready to go to
hearing for Dr to examine it in any way
shape or form to evaluate it and take
any
action would be unusual other than a
very technical matter of you know you
put something in the tax portal for the
budget but you have it in the wrong
account code other than that we're
neutral to those numbers so if the bill
is asking Department of Revenue at that
stage to say aha we see what you're
appropriating and this is on a district
because we operate our an our work
doesn't really aggregate until later
we're looking at individual districts
and their budgets so we would be looking
at a school district's recommended
budget in light of a
predetermined minimum and even there as
I said this would be novel that we would
look at and say your Appropriations in
your school budget even before you've
gone out for the vote is somehow not
meeting this minimum is that the intent
of the bill is for us to check that the
the
the uh let me say how I this so the
found I I think what I'm hearing is that
is that the Department of Education
would need to calculate the foundation
opportunity budgets certainly before the
budget cycle for school districts which
starts let's say October 1st November
1st something like that but but would
would you'd have to have the the
foundation opportunity budgets for every
District calculated before that yes um
so one way to do this is to have use lag
in the data so and that's typically and
the aggregation process that's not in
the bill as proposed right you're
talking about amending this is your pro
this is yeah your process I mean the the
the let let me let me make it clear what
the what the Bill's intent is not that
it is not the Bill's intent for every
local school district to for every um
local property taxpayer or the local
property taxpayer School District to pay
for 58% of their Foundation opportunity
budget Statewide AC
Statewide the state would be responsible
for
42% the locals would be responsible for
58% but obviously depending upon um
valuations and you know property Val
property um yeah assessed property in
each of those districts that those
percentages would vary the the the
dollar the
tax the tax rate per thousand would be
the same across the board I think one of
the and I think Bruce and I need to
spend more time thinking about this um
the aggregation process the calculating
the grant that's all education that
would assume that's responsibility not
dr's responsibility um I think one of
the other mix matches we have that would
be more of dr's responsibility is um a
$5 tax rate per thousand
um it eventually a tax rate turns into a
tax effort and I think that's where
maybe uh things could get a
little uh dicey is is basically a $5 tax
rate on EV raises hypothetical dollars
that the local is actually going to
raise and to determine if the locals
actually raised it is actually a Dr
process and I think Bruce and I have
talked whether are there opportunities
for this to create weird Loops in the
system where we're
now basically saying budgets are not
sufficient and I don't know we haven't
since the Bill's never been enacted it's
like hard for St so so you know let let
me let me um let me sort of step forward
a little bit
the
there's we we may we may be jumping too
far uh getting into something where the
bill does not get into the the reason
this number is calculated is so that the
department can calculate the grant the
foundation Opportunity
Grant yeah we're not talking about a
separate tax line for the for the local
contribution I I representative Luna I
agree I as I looked at it I thought this
in some ways functions mechanically for
us or practically as does uh educations
work with adequacy it comes up with an
estimate right and it is a number um and
and we come up with the swept warrant
numbers in advance so it's also
available to a school district so the
idea that a foundation opportunity
budget amount would be calculated by
education in the same time frame make
that makes perfect sense the other two
things again we we developed the swept
amounts um they were already available
last year as early as September and
they're they're given out through the
warrants and so forth so districts know
that by early November they know the
adequa the current adequacy Aid uh
estimates a solid number if this new
number was introduced as
well right now at that point nothing's
changing
so far for Dr I just wanted to CL and
see if if I'm point and I I think this
could all be calculated at the
Department of Education yeah I I I think
it's not I don't know if it's if there's
a role for Dr to play um and I don't
know if the bill needs clean up to
Define roles better but but that's I
don't because at the end of the day
you're calculating two things Mark
you're calculating the foundation
opportunity budget and then the
foundation Opportunity
Grant and the only the only thing that's
different between those two numbers is
this local contribution which based on
this early draft okay is $5 per thousand
of that Municipal Municipal
municipalities valuation I think it's
right there the novelty occurs to Dr the
quote local contribution the tax dollars
raised from the the the school
district's voters right is only
determined right now for Dr at the very
end of our process of setting the tax
rates it is the what's left has to be
raised through that local school
rate so introducing the idea that
somehow the local contribution has to be
a certain amount or a certain percentage
or any kind of development like that at
the beginning of this of the
process that's novel and I didn't know
that we had a role necessarily but if we
did and it involved maybe I misread
things maybe it was three years ago is
the idea that if we have to try to
figure out if a certain tax rate is
going to accomplish a certain amount of
tax dollars no no good because we
couldn't iterate that way we weren't
we're not built no I think I think this
is a good conversation because I think
it clarifies that that this section of
calculating the foundation opportunity
budget and the found Opportunity Grant
all reside within the Department of
Education and that that
you know that the
cooperation or the collaboration between
um um nhed and the Dr is really to make
sure that they're using the the property
valuations that the most P published
what whatever however you're doing it
now y right yeah right if I might so if
that's working the way it sounds like
it's intended the school district would
be entering into the budget setting
process we're going to be
indirectly aware because we have to be
because of the tax Portal's approach but
we're not intervening at all if there's
any check or balance up to this point it
seems to be on the local school district
to make sure it's complying with the law
in terms of the Appropriations budget
it's putting forward that being said I
did have a question on page eight
section eight of the bill
and that's this is exactly the same area
right now it's very clear that this is
dr's bwick right well no I think this is
the um this is still in the department
of Ed because this is the calculation of
the grant so wait maybe I have the wrong
but it says Dr it says Commissioner of
Dr well then then uh do I have a wrong
Edition or yeah yeah the commissioner of
Revenue on Section 8 tax section right
that's what well maybe I had a different
P pagination I don't know well it says
the commissioner of Revenue
Administration shall compute the rate
percentage of Taxation for school
district purposes from such certificate
I've asked Mark I believe I didn't have
time to look at
1984a but that certificate are the
reports come into education we need the
same we need the numbers but we're going
to calculate the
tax rate or rate percent of Taxation for
school district purposes it's the next
section that again this is novel for us
because at that point in time now we're
at in the fall of tax rate setting all
of the bill has taken effect and done
its
work we're going to look at the total
approved
Appropriations the total non-property
tax revenues to offset those
Appropriations we're going to end up
with a net assessment or the taxes that
need to be raised and we're going to use
the locally uh assessed uh property
value that's relevant to that t that
school
district to determine the local school
rate that's a current approach but
here I i' I'd like to hear you help me
understand what this next section in
this well next part of this section is
attempting to do I I'll I'll read it for
my own sake provide that no separate
increment to the school district tax
rate to raise funds for participating
municipalities minimum of foundation
budget contribution shall be
required if the municipa let me stop
there Y at this point in time we're not
accustomed to having any thought of an
increment we're about to set a t
everything's done our currently but is
this saying that at the time we go to
set a tax rate it's possible
that we have to check to see whether or
not being a
gatekeeper do we have a role to say wait
we can't set the local school rate now
this could be October or November
because and that's the part I don't
think I yeah see I don't I don't think
that's
um I don't think that's the intent in
here and I think we can clean up um this
part section 8 and I think we can clean
up the um the previous section
uh on page
six with respect to that because at the
end of the day
what the only the only thing that really
matters through here is that a
foundation Opportunity Grant is
calculated by the Department of
Education and communicated to the school
districts by November
1st uh I think the preliminary 15th is
the November 15th and um and that um and
that the foundation Opportunity
Grant uh is based on this local minimum
contribution right
that is calculated based on a Statewide
share and then applied at a municipal
level and I think the department can do
that and that local minimum
contribution is not imposed as a
separate tax line right right on the tax
bill it would be part of the local
education property tax approved by if I
might at the time the budget is
developed granted the Appropriations are
well they're a recommendation and let's
leave aside the revenues their estimates
yeah but the Appropriations that's
what's key here is the district is meant
to appr riate at least a minimum but
you're also suggesting that that minimum
be a certain percentage of the total
either in and of itself as a district or
Rel relative to a Statewide goal so it's
possible because you know the
appropriation amount as you develop the
budget again are we looking at it
prevote because the voters can change
things but if it's it's development of
the budget the budget is developed you
have
an ability to to look at those uh
respective percentages Appropriations
are a million swept is
x foundation
Opportunity Grant is the is it the new
adequacy Aid it would so you know that
and then you the net is the local amount
you now have a common ability to Common
sizee it before the budget is Tak
forward so if it's out of line alignment
but that would be the Local District
would have to know that oh the way we've
built the
budget with swept being what it is the
foundation being what it is the local
taxes or contribution would be what it
would be based on the Appropriations you
have the math it doesn't line up in the
sense reiterate the budget because it
wouldn't be meeting again it's not a Dr
check sure we so so maybe maybe we're
not um you
know maybe we're we're we're still not
on the same page on this let me try to
illustrate it through an example so um
let's say that Hopkins Foundation
opportunity
budget as
calculated on page four mhm comes out at
$20
million and let's say
hopkinson's valuation is is a billion
dollars property valuation and let's say
the the local minimum contribution is $3
per thousand so Hopkinson would raise $3
million through a local minimum
contribution that would be a subtracted
from the $20
million Foundation opportunity budget
and it would result in a grant to
Hopkinson of $17 million
MH nothing has gone through Dr yet yeah
so the state has to pay up 17 million
the the the the state Grant to
hopkington would be $17 million and and
and Hopkinton is that goes through all
the school board and the budget
committee and the and the district
meeting I see and the the the at the
district meeting there they um the um
the voters you know the school board
presents a budget of you know $2.2
million right and and when when when
looking at the revenues the the 17
million coming from the state the what
and what coming from different sources
hopkins's going to have to raise another
another you know say say $4 million and
it will do that through a local um
education property tax and that's where
the Dr becomes involved okay at that
stage um we don't have anything to do at
that State this is a pre vote the
budget's been developed correct in
accordance with all that meets every bit
of the law it meets the intent of the
law it's going out for vote it might get
amended up or down or sideways and so
forth uh yearend fund balance from a
school districts alter things some but
that's
normal I think we'd be calculating a
local school rate just as we always
would yeah and just as if and I know
this is Mak complex simple for my
sake Foundation all of the work of
developing the foundation opportunity
cost and the grant is all in the
background to Dr just as adequacy Aid is
we need a number for a district how it's
developed is not the black box but it
could be to us we just need education to
tell us what it is for Hopkin School
District that's what it sounds like here
and I'm happy if you're an agreement
that we don't have particular roles in
the midst and especially if we don't
have anything to do with trying to
calculate a tax rate before we calculate
the tax rate and and just if that's then
I'm really happy in the scenario you
described that's easy peasy the scenario
where that scenario could get I don't
know if there's a if the if the intent
is to do something else what if
Hopkinton only raised $2 million in
local tax effort what would happen in
that situation that's and so in in
earlier versions of this draft um if
Hopkinson only raised 2/3 of what its
local minimum contribution um was then
uh we we contemplated dick you'll
remember we talked about this um
reducing the the the foundation
Opportunity
Grant by that same percentage
and we took that we took that penalty
out because
we didn't feel that that taking money
away from schools would be the right
thing to do um but if if it's an
incentive if it's a if it's a stick yeah
to to require the local school district
to raise the appropriate local minimum
then it could go back in we have the
Lang that Happ if a District's uh
approved a cap which is substantially
lower tax cap tax cap I I uh I don't
think it would be substantially lower in
these cases I mean we've seen it happen
no no no but no but they they you know
given how we're funding it right now
yeah yeah um but not not in these not I
mean so the $5 per th000 or $3 per
thousand is more a measurement than it
is actually interacting with the tax
system right it's it's it's an it's it's
a way for the Department to to to
calculate the grant based on the
Foundation opportunity budget okay and
um and obviously everything works best
when when when that school district is
funded just like Bill was saying through
that integrated approach involving local
and state that partnership between local
and state if if the local is going to
disregard its portion of that and say oh
the grant we're getting from the state
is enough then that's not a good that's
not a good solution
question it is a partnership repres now
I'm not sure if I just got thrown off
track but
um the whether it's $5 $3 or wherever it
gets set it's characterized as a quote
minimum Foundation budget
contribution right so I mean the
question that I heard Mark rais is what
happens if the municipality raises less
but it's a minimum they're obligated to
raise that much if it was n a minimum it
would become another form of the issue
we currently have with swept where uh
the use of excess swept is to you know
offset other obligations right so so I
think I I like this the way I'm reading
it in the bill which is it's a minimum
it's an obligation and the state only
makes up the difference to the extent
that the difference is needed
well that's good to the extent that it's
needed yes 20 million you talk it's only
million that the state portion you said
3 million would be paid by the local and
17 million by the state correct or 20
yeah 17 million what happen if the
district uh appropr needs 15 million not
70 I'm sorry I missed that that they
that they raised more money than the Min
than the minimum they only require 15
million instead of that instead of the
million they rais more they rais more so
they have excess
yeah um this is essentially a reciprocal
of the same outcome we're currently
dealing with with swept yeah I I'm
um so so let's let's so you know we're
sticking with Hopkinson for example um
the
the the foundation opportunity budget
for a town like Hopkinson would would
very likely be substantially less than
we're currently paying for you know for
our education and when we calculated at
three years ago I think hopkington had
maybe a $20 million budget and the
foundation opportunity budget was like
16 million so it's doubtful that
Hopkinson would be satisfied with just
the $16 million budget let alone even go
lower than that now for the city of
Manchester the foundation oper operating
opportunity budget would be
substantially
higher and and could it be that that the
city of Manchester says you know what
we're good with the foundation
Opportunity Grant and we're not going to
put a dime uh towards this well we did
have an early a provision in an earlier
draft of this that if you don't
contribute um your 100% share
of your minimum local contribution then
your foundation Opportunity Grant gets
red pro-rated by that same amount so if
Manchester came in at zero then you
wouldn't get a foundation Opportunity
Grant either
um would would yeah then you'd have zero
budget yeah
um so so would would it make sense to
have that stick back in here to so that
if if uh if a district says well you
know what um I like the found Manchester
I like the found Foundation opportunity
budget but I really only need 90% of it
so I'm only going to put in 90% of the
um the U the local minimum
contribution why should they have that
option well I'm just saying the the
other options Mary where is that they
put in zero and they get all of the
Grant or they
um but no I don't think that's I don't
think that's going to happen because I
think the yeah I don't think it's gonna
Happ well well no I don't think they're
allowed to do that in the bill where the
if the $5 is a measurement then then I'm
not going to if they decide to say well
I would like more money so my local
minimum is zero so give me more money
that's I don't no no no no no that's not
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying
if if if Manchester was satisfied with
the grant yeah as as being with the
assumption that they're their budget
yeah with the Assumption they're putting
a contribution in yeah it the the the
grants calculated based on based on
their their local minimum
contribution if they decide not to put
the local minimum and this is a good
thing to test if they don't want to put
the if they don't put the local minimum
contribution in there should they get
the grant at
all and I think that's a that's a policy
it's so that would uh that's a policy
decision of course and that would not
create any
um mechanical issues or technical issues
whether you went one way or the other
with that um the other potential again
this is we know how this is going to
work for 90% of school districts or we
have an idea we can hypothesize how it
work for most school districts would
there ever what would
um I guess now we're getting to the
mechanic I think we just kind of
discussed it what what mechanically
happen if your um State Grant was 17
million and you only wanted to have a
total budget of 15 million that's where
I don't if that's another again unlikely
to happen well I mean there there's a
couple ways you could do that if if the
grant was 17 million and you only want a
budget of 15 million then then ra then
rather than putting 3 million in as the
local contribution and having a budget
of 20 million then maybe you
put maybe you have a local contribution
tion of 2 million and your your Grant
gets reduced by or 2 and A5 million your
Grant gets reduced by a similar amount
and you get to 15 million I mean that
could be calculated by the local school
district um but but that would require a
a
pration um provision in here and that's
a policy discussion policy consideration
that that that we would have to have you
know is that is that good for kids is
that good for I mean what you know what
do we want to do and I like I said my
original the original draft I put
together on this prior to even before
filing because like we pulled it out of
1680 had that Pro rating um U provision
in there
so I could certainly put it back in the
way it would play out actually I think
the way it would play out is say your
state Grant was 17 million you only
wanted to budget 15 million um you would
have you
would uh you would want to just build up
a trust fund or something you would not
I mean ideally you just wouldn't cut
your
budget you would spend the foundation
opportunity budget essentially I think
that's how it
would use kind of like I mean I think
you probably would but the question is
should you get it at all if you don't
put anything you don't try to if you
don't if if you if
you yeah if you ignore that very first
part um was this like a maintenance of
effort yeah yeah I think that's the way
to think of it I I I actually think
we're getting uh I actually don't think
this is mechanically a thing that's
gonna happen so so what what do you want
to do oh no I was just going down I I
don't think there's a I don't think
there's a technical issue here because I
think you would you would just build a
school that has that provides a
foundation opportunity budget so but I
just went down that R sorry went down
that rabbit hole I I don't know if
there's
G names yeah I think this is um related
um I believe Massachusetts has a
provision that enables a school district
to come forward and engage in a dialogue
with the
state if it believes it it um
can get the outcomes we're talking of
outcomes
and spend a lower amount than the
foundation budget has identified as
needed so there's a process that they
have in Massachusetts to
reduce below what the formula says the
outcome the budget should be and um and
then there's agreement on that and life
goes forward and everybody's happy
because you know uh good outcomes and uh
spending
less so that maybe we need to take a
look at that
M okay sure so if we were to do that
would we have to do some kind of a
demonstration first that demonstrates
that your children are achieving to that
level with this amount of money so that
you've got evidence yeah I think that's
part of the Massachusetts process that's
that's what I was thinking too thank you
do do you know do they have that in
Statue
okay but I think getting back to the
other point who was mentioned um there's
no problem to raise more than the
minimum either that's
correct that's
important now while we're talking about
that since you brought that up Glen
um there
uh I don't know if Massachusetts has
this if you raise more than the minimum
um
that no I'm thinking of something else
sorry the psea fed's kicking
in watch out that stuff gives you a
what's that that stuff gives you a it's
bad it's bad yeah the the other the
other thing I wanted to discuss was uh
some of the sped data uh chairman lad
that you were interested in looking at
and we discussed it earlier the weights
um so actually um I have some data on
high cost bed
students the student the invoices they
submitted the state to get sped Aid
which means their sped cost are higher
than uh this is from 2021 their sped
costs were higher than 59,000 y and that
student the invoices they sent to the
state and their disability so that is
the uh data I have relative to high cost
bed students related to disabilities um
I think you all of you were discussing
earlier can I get more granular than
that with the
doe2 no I have sped cost by District
broken up by Elementary Middle High
School I have some um functions or
objects object codes within sped data um
um but I can't get too granular with
do25 SP what we were trying to do we
were looking at in that report that you
know the commission report we were
looking at awaited uh calculation based
upon
4.29 yep what we're what we're
suggesting is what we worked on last
year in that legislation that we passed
out of the house education committee
here where there'd be category ories uh
and we suggested three
categories and breaking those uh high
cost
IEPs into a a different weighted
category than one where a student is
spending less than so many hours per
week or less than 80% of their time
within and I thought and represent
cascaden correct me if I'm wrong but I
thought under under idea Part B there's
requirement to submit this information
to State
sped so don't you have this data we have
sped I mean you've seen the data we have
sped data on disability type I I I
recognize and I've gotten that and
you've had that for years the number in
each IEP
category um but you're saying
expenditures Ida
expenditures no that's the the full-time
that you have within the the the each
category
area um it doesn't talk about costs at
all so what we're looking for is there
are there any costs an average cost for
example like for a kid the kids that are
in that category a category B and
category C which is the residential
placements which I think you told me
there are close what to 700 kids there
in that category yep so we're just
trying to get the data so we recognize
that many states many states are are are
waiting this out by
categories um we'd like we' like to
contemplate doing the same thing so how
do we get that data you actually yeah so
you brought up a point I didn't think
about so the doe2 is really rolled up
not a lot of granularity there um the
sped aid program we have a a lot of data
on high cost fed students I didn't even
think about at the idea within this is
not my program we'd have to bring in
Becky for that um but if that's
something basically it sounds like what
you're looking for
is each sped student served in the not
not every school district every well
most school districts have sped cost not
every of them access their Ida or or or
they have different Ida programs um but
if we just took the sort of raw Ida data
we might be able to answer that question
average cost per disability type
if if that data is entered into the
special ed
database not every District participate
in use of that database yeah it's not
it's not perfect and also I there SP I'm
sure there's there's I know there's a
bunch of SP expenditure is not covered
by Ida so I don't even know how
comprehensive it would be it would be
qualified um just like the high cost fed
student data is qualified it only
includes 700 students instead of the
30,000 that we
have would it be in the
system
uh dis so by cost or I'm not aware of
now on this fact sheet from the feds
M it says children with IEPs age five
who are enrolled in kindergarten uh and
age six through age 21 served and then
has these indicator these
areas uh indicator 58 inside riger class
80% or more of the
day indicator 5B inside riger class less
than 40% of the day in indicator C in
separate schools residential facilities
or homebound Hospital type
programming uh so that's the stuff we're
trying to get a hold
of
so yeah as far as getting
really good data and making we it's not
going to just not going to happen good
data relative to speding cost um but if
you're looking for a ballpark figure or
a model or assumpt a really heavily
assumed prediction um we could try
something like that
um basically I think what you were
discussing two years ago and also uh
yesterday that 4.2 weight is somehow
dividing that up and saying putting sped
students into categories and so getting
to the totality of that 4.28 but if
there's a student with a lowc cost
disability in one District they're fully
they're compensated at a lesser rate
than if a student has a high cost so
yeah I think we have a lot of different
ways to attempt to get that data we have
about you know till February 15th to
figure it out
um I just don't know what path you think
we should pursue represent cascaden I
just wondered um
sped directors put in a lot of this
detailed data in the Nessa system and
I'm wondering if it's worth having Jane
berson come up um if she knows in
advance what we're looking for and Becky
and Becky for Deb yeah can I ask a
question about the doe2 yes in the doe2
is there a line that just says special
ed costs so um uh we have um it's
program 1200 which includes like special
programs um that's uh pretty reli that's
well that's more reliable than the sped
breakdown data then we have a sped
breakdown data that breaks down sped
instruction sped support sped legal sped
Administration so we do have data so we
we there's an approximate aggregate cost
I think it's almost a billion dollars
yep like 700 District 700 so would it be
feasible if we using those lines from
the do 25 if we were to determine that
um the state of New Hampshire is going
to buy uh cover 50% or 75% of all sped
costs for school
district um to me that would be kind of
a clean easy way I've noticed that a lot
of school districts a lot of states are
doing those kinds of things um instead
of trying to um do District by District
if we could just take that amount by
district and do a
percentage so we have um we have the
total sped spend as reported by the
districts
y um so we can do whatever you want with
that data um what
um it's possible if we legislate it and
fund it you could you could you could
write that bill with the data we have
okay thank you
but then you're not getting any um
differentiated cost per student based on
disability what what yeah what the yeah
what you know we we uh looked at this
and initially I set it up by the 13 IEP
or disability
areas but then recognizing after talking
to directors in the field any one of
those
categories could involve a lot more time
spent I and delivering that service a
speech pathologist could be working with
a young person every day for you know an
hour a day maybe or it could be only uh
a a younger child in a group of five
learning how to say the letter r in
kindergarten which is not kindergarten
but maybe first grade or so and you have
five in the group for two a half hours a
week but but the issue I see here with
this funding all special ed
$27,000 a
kid that's opening up this thing to
abuse uh you know man as a
superintendent of schools I could say
wow I know how I can latch into somebody
we're just going to put more IEPs down
or we're going to monitor more kids so
and and so I think there's I'd like to
see us if we can if we can now doing the
cat Aid part or the special Aid we know
that we got that information that's a
given
but on in terms of the other two
categories or whatever categories we're
have I think we need to work with Becky
fet and we need to look with the
directors and Jan berser on and and try
to nail this thing down I think it can
be done uh when I initially did this I
did it by IEP I found out that's not
necessarily going to make it it's got to
be done by time spent with the adult but
Rick you have to remember too the kids
kids have more than one disability get a
primary disability so and but some are
getting have multiple disabilities the
other can I just raise one more issue we
have uh Federal Law requires school
districts to serve kiddos three through
five now do we look at that at all in
terms of we don't there preschool
special ed money but that doesn't cover
all the costs that a school district
incurs
most school districts run an integrated
preschool um how do we do we offer any
assistance for that at all and should we
question I was waiting for Mark to say
whether he's dealing with that how how
are you is that money now currently
coming from HHS for grades three three
through five there's a prek Ida Grant I
don't have the numbers off top of my
head our cost our 780 million and I
would have to break it down by I don't
have a prek breakdown but I have an
elementary uh breakdown um but as we all
know um Federal money and state money
does not even come close to covering all
sped costs so I mean that's that's well
lastly though we know the IEP
stipulates the number of contacts and
the length of the contacts within the
IEP that information is out it may be
out there on those I APS and may be held
within the districts
however I I think we should be able to
grab it and get a hold of it
somehow the amount of service provided
the amount of time service provided
exactly it could be so much for the the
fiscal therapist is in there the
occupational therapists is in there with
the child the the uh learning
disabilities they're all there add them
all up that's the amount and that's in
the IP the amount of service
provided
and it it's it it's it's going to be
something new but it's something that I
think is relevant for us to know too so
the only thing I would say is um talking
about novel aspects of the bill and this
concept is novel in a sense we've we've
kind of been studying for a little bit
um but we've haven't done it dug too
deep uh you've been studying it for
years I would ask uh I recommend that
you bring in us this our SP Bureau in
right away because they're going to tell
you where the where the dead ends are um
we talked about that just earlier but
you know I'm concerned back in 2010 when
I first gotten this joint here back in
2008 our Statewide population was what
uh uh uh 210,000 kids
maybe okay and then and now where are we
down in terms of residents 165 164
somewhere in that neighborhood 155 admr
number of kids that were in special back
when I came in
30,000 the number today 30,000 that's
right so proportionately that ratio is
going you know we're having more kids in
this program this is a program which
seems to be growing in our state or
we're identifying better than we have in
the past which I think we are and we're
getting earlier into this game I I think
we need to get this information to me
this is a critical factor for any
formula we have whether it's outcome
based or if it's input based we need to
have this in our
formula the only other things uh just as
far as scheduling in the the work you
want to try to um accomplish in the next
couple weeks yeah getting the SP buau in
to see what data is available and then
if you're if you're interested in
1586 seeing what we can do with that
data um you'd want to start to come up
with the methodology right away so then
we can get the data pull so then we
could pull it into the put it into the
formula is Rebecca in the grand State
Building yep good I'll be there tomorrow
and and I have a meeting over there
dealing with another topic but uh if I
could arrange the time to meet with
Rebecca and try and get this thing going
a little bit um it would certainly be
appreciated and and relative to 1586 um
if you want to talk about accountability
bring in Dr Green um that's Nate bring
in K bring in the whole crew but so
that's that's the only I can I can work
with representative luno and and and
tune up that spreadsheet um to have that
for you but um great just there's a lot
of other work there you're going going
down so yeah
okay do we have any other issues with
Dr or with doe on this right
now what we plan on doing right after
and right now is what we wanted to do is
that we were going to where are we going
now um leaving today what kind of
research are we looking to acquire and
move towards and and because we have an
opportunity here we have a few days
where we can have a research who has now
disappeared uh do some work for us or
or or ask doe to help us search out or
in fact if if we need anything from Dr
um so from the committee um anything yes
do we need to I know um uh Andrew
valinsky had spoken about the um Title
One proog Esa which covers um a lot of
kids across the state and the um schools
in need of improvement that the names
have changed since do we need to have
somebody update us on those kinds of
things in terms of the work that they're
doing and how they identify schools um
is that something we need to know about
CSI schools that's part of the
accountability program the federally
mandated or regulated accountability
program so that would be um uh Dr Green
and his
employees so would that play into
1586 I'm not sure well I think in the
accountability on the accountability end
would um you know we there's there two
categories even it
yeah
CSS and what happens as a result of that
what kind of support do they get or not
get and at least
know it's Title One
money yeah okay um so we can ask for
that information um in regard to the
other bills on on Swap on in regard to
uh uh the base cost and do we need uh
more information on anybody come in or
anything additional for the special ed
aspect of 27 Grand there on the other
bills um chairman yeah I have a question
I originally saw um the sweat belt by
itself because it addressed the court
summary
judgment in
1686 or
1586 I can't remember which one which
one have we've been talking about
1586 all right a dress is
swept so do we break out sweat and
continue to move all the components we
want in that 16 in that sweat Bill and
take it out of this one so that we have
a bill for swep and a bill for the
opportunity grants the funding mechanism
or do we put it all
together so
there's it depends on how your funding
formula is if we're if we're if we were
to move forward forward with no funding
formula changes and just swept reform
than um than I think the provisions in
um in 16 1686 1586 no 1586
1686 um are um are correct uh uh I think
we may want to
consider possibly amending that to
bect collected locally like like it's
done now and send it all in yeah and
then all the districts would get their
adequacy Grant as a direct Grant from
the state as opposed to collect some of
it save some of it send the rest um up
um that's one thing I suggest yeah I
would say we need a discussion on that I
think the uh the options are clear we
can
um take the uh dear 1686
Bill and go forward with it as it is
there's one option that's keeping uh
sending only excess swept to the state
and and coping with the uh relatively
minor problems of uh of the negative tax
rate or um there are some other issues
excess sweat cost changing I I forget
what they are but in any event uh um we
can we can do it that way or we can do
it the way it is in six
1586 which takes all the money and sends
it in except for a
3% um amount to for process respect the
fact that it cost municipalities some
money to process this stuff um and um
that also includes the uh free and
reduced price lunch uh
free and reduced price homeowner rebate
program low and moderate low and
moderate I low and moderate same thing
no it's not
um yeah right sorry we can we can do it
that way which is a more comprehensive
approach more of a reform and that's the
way it was originally proposed that's of
course what I favor um I think there's
some Merit to taking it out of uh the
big Bill the foundation Bill and dealing
with it separate Seely because who knows
what's going to happen in the future and
one may go all the way and one may not
um and uh Rand uh the Rand case will
probably be be resolved at least that
part of the Rand Case by going ahead
with with that particular bill so I I
I'm recommending that we have a
discussion on which way to go on these
two we can talk about the pros and cons
more completely I I I agree with you
represent Ames I think we're going to
need to have a separate time set aside
for swept there are those that want to
leave swept the way it is right
now there are those that you would like
to see swep handled the way that bill I
handed out to you this morning where
they can keep the access but they're
required to use the excess monies for
certain educational needs those are all
things which could happen you know bills
can be
amended so so I think we uh we need to
have a discussion on SWAT
yeah thank you well we're on the swept
um because the amendment addresses the
swept amount of
334 million while I have Dr and doe here
is there anybody
who will we be able to talk about how
that number was set and why it stays
that amount in when we talk about the
amendment or is this the time right now
to talk about
it have you seen this amendment
so is the question how we got our swept
number yeah that's one of them so it
used to be a rate it used to be a rate
uh then it became a flat dollar so the
way swept works it's 363 million over
whatever our non-utility tax Bas is so
now it's a fixed dollar amount it used
to be a rate I think it uh $5 or
$660 $66 6 C 60 cents per thousand in
1999 and the legislature would lower
that rate I believe almost every year
for a number of years and then in
2005 the legislature set it as a fixed
dollar amount $363 million at least uh
and it has been that since
2005 we can only pip pothesized that
that 363 number was similar to what they
were currently doing or it was a Target
they liked so by way I don't think we
can tell or unless someone who's ever
whoever was there uh 15 years ago or so
by setting that rate that's in that
soall I saw that for the first time this
morning so I haven't had really time to
think about it but by putting at that
proposed rate lesser than the
3063 would that eliminate excess that it
it wouldn't eliminate it but it's it's
$29 million which is the amount of
excess swept less than what's being
raised right now so but it wouldn't
eliminate it wouldn't eliminate future
ex okay so I switch to say yeah yeah
yeah we have
to um because it's in statute that we
have to raise a certain amount of
money isn't it true that the excess swep
towns keep their money and other towns
have to make up the difference to get to
that legislated
amount
no Bruce how do we how do we chew it up
here's how it works uh sometime toward
the end of each May the equalization
Bureau of Department of Revenue finishes
equalizing the property values of every
municipality at that point they hand off
that list to the municipal Bureau and
then we just follow the dictates of the
existing law uh with the legislature
allows us to you to round to the nearest
Half Penny which is why you see on that
summary sheet sometimes the State
education uh tax rate is uh $1
45.5 if you
will and then um having determined that
that one rate will when applied against
the equalized values create at least
$363 million we then use the equalized
property values of all 259
municipalities and and basically create
a common sizing or a percentage basis
and then go back and take those
percentages against the 363 thus giving
uh one municipality whatever that dollar
is that amount is then taxed locally
using the locally assessed values of
that property tax year thus giving rise
to the annual question why isn't the
swept rate in one community identical to
the other because they won't be thank
you you're welcome I've always wondered
that
okay so are there any other topics which
we need to get information for when we
come
back
yes if
1586 is moving forward at some point
we're going to hit a total button and
say Here's how much this is going to
cost
where's it coming
from can we do it seems to me swept is
the place it's going to come
from I I can cover that uh
so the scenarios I described to kind of
just Target numbers um when you receive
a town by town for that bill um I will
show you what you're getting under
current law and what you're getting
under the proposed Bill and and so when
I was talking about total spend I was
talking about Statewide aggregate total
so part of the way the mechanics of 1586
works and some districts will um so
everyone will be sending 97% of their
swept to the state so um some
communities with ex High excess swept
will be sending a lot a lot of money to
the state um then the way it works out
with their Foundation opportunity budget
if you have a large property tax base
that $5 or $3 whatever the rate ends up
being in the sort of final uh uh or when
you see your spreadsheet um if it's $3
that's going to for a community with a
large tax base that might raise a lot of
money meaning they sufficiently have a
minimum contribution to have them meet
their uh Foundation opportunity budget
which means they would receive no State
funding which
means they're kind
of neutral there but they just sent 97%
of their swep to the state so there will
be some communities where uh uh they'll
be sending money to the state and
receiving zero dollar so that's where
some Revenue will be coming in um that's
the way it's designed so uh uh but when
I say net change total say so if I say
$200 million net change total that under
the the way I talk about that number
that would need to find a revenue Source
other than swept or or if you modify
swept in some way but under the um it
gets a little complicated but some of
it's coming from essentially property
taxes some of the funding is coming from
property taxes it'll make more sense
when you see a town by town but my my
concern when this is finance yes is is
we've got a Delta and we're going to
have to come up with how we how do we
fund the Delta it and and that's a good
that's obviously a key part uh so if the
net change total isga 8 million then
Finance doesn't need to fund the Delta
because it's actually saving the state
$18 million um if the net change total
is 200 million Finance well ways and
wans of Finance need to work together
and find 200 million
so you'll see that in the spreadsheet um
but yeah that's that's definitely a key
key part of the conversation all right
how much we have in rainy day fund the
education trust fund is is looking
really good um we have the budget in the
audience um it's it's it's it's looking
good the r fund's looking good but
obviously well budget director will tell
you how budgeting works you want to
budget off revenues not off Surplus but
um that's a whole other conversation
yeah so we'll have swep on the next next
meeting agenda as well can we just ask
for a balance on the education trust do
you have a balance oh so the the cfer
just completed the caffer said I think
161 million that's what I read 160 uh
this is now Finance needs to get briefed
on this but um we're over we're going to
predict it over budget by 31 million in
adequacy um or adequacy EFA
Charters so um um but revenues are doing
really well and in the Surplus statement
all of you adopted um you were
predicting the Surplus to grow so the
Surplus is predicted to grow based on
all the metric I have but um I can't
really give you a number until we have
the um act for completed um which shows
161 for the fiscal year ending
23 you have questions add you need some
revenues yeah we need you I'm waiting
for that total button to get hit so yeah
okay well if if uh folks have some
things they'd like to put on the agenda
please you know send me an email and
I'll make sure we talk to Jan and get
that on on the docket for the next
meeting on on the 19th at 10:00 down
around the corner on the second floor
209 so with that thank you very much for
coming from the revenue folks and from
the education folks appreciate
it um Mr chair just a quick you know
calendar question so we got six weeks
before that February 15 are you thinking
that we would spend at least a day a
week or more than that or do you and and
is the ultimate goal for the educ full
education committee to accept something
to bring to the floor is that where
we're yeah the goal for this is that
there be a recommendation come out of
this subcommittee to the full committee
and and you know the ones which will be
voting on the recommendation will be
only those that are on education policy
that's the way this was set up however
however we certainly encourage Ways and
Means and finance to give us some good
input here uh but we have to have a
recommendation if it comes out like a 3
three vote um it's probably going to
come out of uh on the other side of the
coin 2 1010 and then it's going to be
you know another one of those debates in
house FL we'll be back at square one
yeah so what we got to do is really have
to work hard and find out are there some
things that we can do to you know uh
move forward with
something
than no no no all all this all this is
set up to do is this we have to